please
that means
right good morning everybody and welcome
to the plans committee meeting of the
6th of October
memory realize that five of this
morning's applications been carried all
up in the meeting which should have
inhaled the day after I met Majesty
derived in that region have to be
canceled so
um the first item on the agenda is
apologies
something yeah one apology councilor
Watson Council
substituting and I had a large email
from councilor Craig and giving her
apologies she got severe vote thank you
and she was trying to get a substitute
with their age and engage yourself
okay right we move on then item two on
the agenda I'll pay his bank to 16 and
then management of the meeting held on
the 26th 28th of July I moved on from
the chair
so any like the second one Council of
God
and we all built on those moments we
okay thanks for the mountain
councilor Brown
cancer Christine oh thanks
for the lock Stone
councilor Pennington abstain that's the
wise man
that's following four and three
abstentions too thank you
foreign
[Music]
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is being
considered
elected members of Devon County Council
and chairman Parish account forward who
have considered a planning application
by both of their membership of that
parents or older personal interest
and they're deemed to have considered
the application separately on the
express view of that council do not by
remembers concerned who consider the
application of match
and it's only at least committee meeting
we're all up to their information is
available
[Music]
on item four is agreements of the agenda
between past one and two while there's
no problem
uh item six is public participation and
obviously where I advise the committee
of any prior requests to speak and then
with the public
we've actually got
of Poland contributors to some extent to
be read out 17 today to contribute
towards the sixth planet application
and
we've got whatever yeah I'll go through
each of them
to speak uh members of the public to
that was to be read out against the
London to Valley Road application
uh at the support from the application
speaking and then the change the one
we've got
uh one speaker in support the political
changing rooms we've got
support from the applicant
often in London we've got uh one speaker
in support two speakers in support one
is Council Rock whose speakers award
member and then we'll leave the room
technique by the park in the debate
uh
related Cottage there is one speaker
against
that the parish council of Peter M was
speaking against them
Harold Connell I believe the neighbor is
speaking against them
there's one speaker in support on behalf
of the Africa
land of corner of Peter James again
speaking against this is on behalf of
the parish council
John and Pat Freeman is down here a
letter to be ready General doesn't say
whether they're in favor or against
and then we've got Graham Eastern
support who's the African and councilor
Hodson has sent a letter in a ward
member to be read out she's away at the
moment
and we've had a late uh speaker against
Becky Chalmers with a letter to be read
out so that's the list of all the
speakers this morning
right
[Music]
sorry those that I read actually
it's not available
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then there are up to two public
speakers
um who wish to speak against an
application there are three names for
their statements and I said that we've
had a couple of memory statement today
and people should restrict the two today
four really both sides but no more than
that
so there are two speakers against and
then we have two puppets being within
supporting the application I'm
terminated the board member in who's
wore that application polls they've no
time and that they can speak on the
applications
[Music]
and then that was committee will debate
the application with any questions that
they may have to be approved
right I think
John we're not expecting any
um
fire alarms I was talking in that
they've done the testing of them so on
we move on to item seven now which is
the planning applications
and the information that recommendations
and advice contained in the report are
correct engage in preparation which is
more than 10 days in advance of the
committee movement
due to these kinds of constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports we'll be provided in writing or
all of it like the committee didn't know
and we move on then now to our first
application 7A
which is on pages
1777 of your agenda
and Helen our client manager
agenda item relates to outline planning
application reference one sorry and
could you speak into them yeah yeah
um one forward slash one zero one
2014 outm the description development is
up on the screen before you now
um eventually proposes up to 750
dwellings including important for
housing a 50 bed Care Facility a local
Center a primary school new highway
infrastructure including New Hampshire
areas of formal open space and
landscoping and drainage and attenuation
infrastructure this is Atlant Northern
cavali Road
I mean the the application has been
before the council for significant
period of time it does benefit from a
resolution to Grant content from the
plans to be back in 2016 and however
since that time there have been very
ongoing discussions between the
applicant and the landowner to the
extent that a legal agreement was now
assigned so we could bear or not issue a
decision given the passage of time
um it has been necessary to revisit a
lot of the principles that were
considered back in 2016 not only section
106 contributions
um and also
there had been the need for updates in
terms of an ecology and drainage and
highways in particular and all of the
the upgrades of information containing
neurological general report your agenda
report does also include under the
background section at the beginning the
minutes of that meeting in 2016
um so they are there for use of
reference
um
but moving on there are there is just
um a verbal update in terms of a couple
suggested amendments and conditions
within your report so condition two
relates to the time self and submission
of all Reserve matters so I've currently
worth it the conditions requires further
Reserve matters to be submitted within
three years and then all Reserve matters
within seven years now normally on a
proposed of a much smaller scale we
would require all Reserve matters within
three years
um the planning acts do will allow for
alternative time cells to be put forward
and give them scale development it is
um clearly going to be built out over a
number of years and over a number of
phases the Europe is initial suggestion
was that was setting it and for all of
the reserve massive to be submitted the
applicant has requested that that be
extended extended to 10 years
um evidence of similar conditions for
similar scale of development multiple
accounts or
um have recently used the condition
indicating 10 years so it is considered
reasonable to extend that period and
that is the admission of the last
Reserve matters within 10 years there is
also a very minor change the wording
condition 11
um it talks about and this relates to
The Pedestrian Improvement works on
aberton road being required prior to
occupation of any dwelling and reduce
um
for clarity the fundamentally relates to
new students within built build
structure that we use element that
should be extended to within a
non-residential field building on the
side that would relate to the school for
example or the community center and so
they're the only recommended change into
the the conditions within your agenda
reform there is one other update and
that is that we've had a late request
from Devon County Highway Authority
regarding the the heads of terms that
are set out that an offended to your
report
um
there are requests and contributions
towards the bus services and sustainable
plants or something so the Kenway cycle
route the highway Authority have
indicated that they would like
flexibility as to how to spend those
money and to also have the opportunity
to direct those money towards the
Improvement to the Hayward
them out
your officer has expressed concern over
that in terms of the still test
um if if all of those infrastructure
requirements are needed they should all
be put forward and considered
um however that the highway Authority
would like an opportunity and macaron is
appear on the highway of hurricane today
so having discussed with the chair if
the community the group or we would
allow macronas just to explain the
rationale for that after the speaker so
just just array that with more so moving
on now through the presentation
um people you know the the site location
plan showing me the extent of the
application site the cover an error of
50.8 hectare and here's an aerial photo
site outlined in red which just shows
the relationship of the application
designed to to both fiddleford and then
Northern and white would have developers
set very much to the west from Southwest
or Biddeford
this is a more detailed area of photo
now just so that members can appreciate
the relationship of the site to
neighboring neighboring uses you see the
western boundary of the site is clearly
marked by the a39
to the north of the site which is bound
by Atherton Road
beyond the direction where the north
would be the badges wood site which is
recently been subject to uh planning
inquiry and we are awaiting the
inspective decision on that and then
looking across to the East College Park
residential development grade two lifted
Morton house and then quite extensive
Woodland along that eastern boundary and
she and she's proceed down to the South
the southern boundary of the site
informed at the southeast side by the
kingdom Enterprise Park
um
along that Southeastern boundary the the
bulk of the Southern boundaries formed
by residential development and a range
of commercial Museum associated with
Atlantic Atlantic Park which also forms
part of the The Wider allocation for
this so in the local plan
this is a plan that just highlights some
of the the key features of recycling
within the site you can see there are
some series of plantations that are
highlighted there within the center of
the sign is winsford house and
Associated farm buildings
um which includes a more Garden as well
keeping Cottage is identified in the
middle of the fight that doesn't fall
part of the application that that's part
of the application boundary
um and then looking up at the the north
um east of the site you have a separate
unconnected property called little
Morton
um modern Lodge is right up at the
northeast corner outside of the site and
Morton house which I've already
mentioned as you can see
[Music]
um along with the other the industrial
estate down the sound the southeast
corner and the Atlantic Park signed the
image here is obviously quite quite old
because
this is the plan that was submitted with
the application and it just seeks to
highlight more sensitive part of the
bike in landscape and visual impact
there but the areas highlighted in pink
are more
um visible in the landscape they're more
sensitive in terms of views I can see
the topography there they do slope down
and then the boundaries of their sheets
and yellow are the more sensitive
boundaries and as you'll see from the
photo shortly and from the site with it
much of the site is relatively blacked
and contained but there are elements
that are more prominent than the one
that landscape
this is the um plan showing the land
various landscape character in the area
the site is highlighted in red and it
formed the coastal undulating Farm
landscape type
this is a historic England extract map
just showing the relationship of the
fight and lifted building so at the
Northeast point there we have Morton
House and the associated stable
um there is a list of building on Valley
Road to the South and the grouping of
Victor buildings within within Albertson
itself
um received from from the agenda report
that the the building's most impacted by
the development are Morton House and the
churches and Helen's in our team
did the EA flood mapping
on the whole the site is within blood
then one there are the small elements of
blood zone two and three which just
relates to a water course going through
the scientists
and this is the extract from the local
plan policies map so the allocation
itself is repair 501
um it is a mixed use allocation
the policy is quoted in your report
um and this application forms
um significant proportion of that
allocation and the Atlantic guitar and
two maintains being to the staff has
already been built out and there is
Planning Commission in place within the
sort of decline or
and we are down at the Southwest two
separate outline commissions one of the
200 dwellings and one for 61 dwellings
and that would take the total of the
allocated in terms of those areas and
I'm just going to run through some
photos now
um obviously members saw videos and
quite detailed side visit presentation
the way the photos which is orientated
as they start from the northeast corner
and all the way around clockwise
Direction but I will explain
where they are as we go through
so this is Morton House Greg gradually
lifted this sits at the Northeast
boundary of the site as we pan around
you can just see the the site here just
take the other side of the Hedge
um this is the driveway leading up to
Morton house now the conservation
officer has raised
um an observation of potential concern
over the impact on the the setting of
Morton house and how important this is
and the only access point now through to
Morton house with the the driveway in
the trees and it's it's highlighted the
ACT details age when they have
considered that that means that setting
really compelling into account
this shows the relationship with the
College Park development so that's it's
quite tightly to the boundary of the
driveway up to more to the house the
application site is the other side of
the trees and fence and so there is that
separation distance with the driveway
a bit of Walton Lodge which is at the
very healthy point of the site outside
boundary and from Abington Road
and there's just pans around that's a
lot of Northeast portion of the site
Road along the north
viewing that same field from the Western
the western boundary again just hanging
around to the entirety of that field
um this sort of
redundant boundary here the site is on
the left the the land immediately in the
photo here is not part of the
application site
but I've just included this to show that
relationship with with Morton the house
this isn't out of within or the center
of the site and under the theories of
photos that hang around so the which is
looking South you can just make out
um the industrial estate to write down
and again just centering around those
little sensitive
um bits of the site and Landscape terms
you can see up against the boundary
there that there is a undulation and the
land will slow down
and it's just coming around so this is
the application site
in the background now towards the North
and that looking back up to the north as
well
it's better within the site
um beyond the boundary along North in
residential development and Commercial
development associated with with
Atlantic Park
to the Hedgerow and there are some skin
of the country within within the
application site again just panning
around and trying to give members
appreciation of the Topography of the
site this just Zooms in and shows that
relationship with the site with the
kingdom Enterprise Park
um there are there is a condition
recommended there are no assessment
between more money with their massive
layout and design
um meaning as recommended by the
Environmental Protection so given the
approximity to those industrial uses
down to further along
um addicted for the South West corner of
the site and along the southern boundary
is where the sustainable transport link
will connect through to the residential
scheme on the the other side
um and this is roughly where where that
sustainable transport link would go
really
[Music]
um
it's getting everywhere to the western
part of like now this is looking back
towards the North and this is a small
contained particle between the two
retained Woodland plantations and we're
now just hanging around that that
section
and then moving along further towards
the yeast looking at the northern
section of the allocation of the
application site you can do the far
building dissociated with Winston House
can you get me in the center here the
dwelling which is um cottage which sits
outside of the application boundary
again just panning around over to the
eastern boundary and that Woodland that
holds the Eastern extend a bite
and see there are some significant more
um mature trees and in the the sort of
Keepers Cottage there
um
let me do the wall guard and associated
with The Farmhouse
now I think you can approached back to
the main farmhouse
and it's very this is the eastern
boundary at the Northeast part of the
site Morton House is beyond Cliff
sandwiches and there isn't a direct
visual relationship with much of the
fight
this is now the northern section of the
site
um against these properties are actually
being retained and fit outside of the
application site
this is um the land that slopes down
towards action Road
[Music]
this has been currents of access
arrangements to the farm within the site
Barn buildings associated with being
with Winters which house
and it's the various of the northern
section now but looking back on the
North back to the South
panning around that part of the site
again this is the lands now at the
northern section looking down towards
abbottshire road which forms the
boundary
happening
this is the milk Pond area it's it's
sort of contains
habitat in itself to postponed and sort
of treating something around it which
would retain anything promotional
feature
right down the back down into the walls
and looking back at Winston house and
the farm buildings
and we see the the northern section
depending around the
the features would be over in this
little section just beyond the comedian
feel a little bit more questions
um
Atherton Road is overboard with the
northern boundary here
in Alberton Road and some maturity you
can see and looking back around towards
the east
we can see the high road I think in the
ultimate Venture Center maybe near
Aberdeen
again that's the tripod the topography
as you come down belching Road
and these are the dwellings that would
be retained and sit outside of the
application boundary
just in the views from the a39 now so
this is just approaching the big sheet
reduction for the application proposing
the new Junction
opposite the big sheet Junction and both
Junctions would become left in left out
just to show where that that point would
be the application site is along the lap
so you can see action can use on the 839
are limited due to topography and and
the vegetation to further along the a39
going up towards the action roundabout
and this is now coming from the average
human roundabout down site is on the
right and again you can see how
contained it is in visual terms
and if it's coming up to where the
injunction would be on the right hand
side
this is the a39 bridge coming from the
original Direction site immediately on
the right
you can continue along ambition roads
just showing that relationship with the
site again on the right
one point of access would would be at
this side on the right hand side it's a
an early days of development in the
Autumn Lodge Just Over the Hedge near
The Pedestrian Improvement Works will
take take practices around this corner
that notchedness consume
um and there'll be a build out around
this wall to enable pedestrian access
and at the moment it's not possible just
to show that that orientation you can
see The Pedestrian have existing on the
other side so it connects into that to
enable links through to bigger bid this
is looking in the other direction from
the Morton Lodge with that all firming
up against the highway
and again that's just showing how tight
that is at the moment
again just coming across where the new
access will come out
fighters on the left here
and then this is then heading down to
the action brain so the a39 bridge
and then you can see the a39 bridge here
the application does propose pedestrian
links within the site well on site
Frontage up to the bridge and then there
is a contribution proposed so that the
highway Authority can then
and then deliver Highway improvements
from the bridge to aperture which would
be delivered by the highway Authority
and this shows The Verge where that will
take place
this just shows the point of the
connection of the sustainable transport
link
um so the site is on the other side and
this is the point that's been made on
the development carried out by persimmon
so that connection can be made
now just looking at the indicative
examples that were submitted as part of
the application
it is an outline only acts of the
determination though all of the plans
are just illustrative but they do show
how the development can come forward in
the form of pose this is the overall
concept master plan so it's showing how
residential uses can be spread across
the site either highlighted in yellow
you have the source light showing in
blue
full payment Plainfield Shannon green
the brown identified the local Center
and the extra care was shown as being
around the existing Farm building in the
center again it was indicative that just
showed how that overall Quantum of
development can be brought forward I'm
just looking in more detail this is a
land use plan and it gives them quantums
of sort of developable area recognizing
that much of a side would not be
developed through retainable and have a
chat in Parkland areas important to know
the local Center is identified as 0.67
hectare and the section 106 recommends
to secure that Quantum of development
called the local Center however it
wouldn't have to all be provided in one
location together the local Center is
supposed to also include the community
pool
um there would be flexibility for that
that local Center Quantum to be provided
throughout the development as human
regret the school sites you can see
there as well
um which which would be secured
to provide reform insurance
this shows the usage combined with the
green infrastructure again can
understand up to what extent would be
built development of what extent will be
retained habitat Beach and Woodland and
Parklands
this show to the indicative density plan
the the darker shaded areas so where
there could be a higher density of
development the yellow was a no identity
the the density of the assumed extends
between 25 go into the hectare up to 45
hectare they're obviously in certain
areas that can accommodate a higher
density and that would be informed by
landscape sensitivity
um at the detailed stage
and we're building Heights with
consecutively shown that the areas of
shaded dark and the more dark boundary
could accommodate higher buildings the
the invicted of Montana assumed maximum
height of three stories
green infrastructure provision across
the site the application proposed with
the mix of formal and informal open
stains
um retained with them from substitutions
and the Wetland feature as well
this is the proposed surface water
scheme that would be the condition
requiring a detailed scheme to come
forward on a phase by phase basis there
is a proposals with that performed
features to be provided up in the
northwest corner that's a shame yeah it
just shows how the base base is the
certainly descriptive at work
this is the bowel drainage indicative
blue stone how that can connect through
you know pipe system and importantly the
point of connection being further
insulong action road which have been
agreed with Southwest water both in
terms of the capacity of the system and
also the connection the inside and being
provided by South Africa on pipe
diameters
this showed some habitat creation by
diversity Net game
um the the by the rest of the Net game
proposal is a combination of on-site and
off-site on-site provision would be just
under three percent of the required 10
um there there's a variety of ways
habitats have been created and brought
forward and there are conditions there's
a condition requiring a landscape
ecological management plan and a
specific biodiversity enhancement scheme
to come forward at a native stage in
terms of the remaining
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which is one of the key habitat types
that belongs within development and also
0.9 perhaps are the lowland Meadows
Herbert grassland that the direct
response to the habitat type that I lost
and it is within the closest Energy site
this is the highway concept plan how
accessible determination at this stage
Community there are two points of access
to the page onto action Road a new
Junction on VA 39 and then we have the
sustainable transport Link in the South
there is an indicative link to the South
West as well and the development that's
the other side of that boundary which
has consent for 200 dwelling there is a
condition on that and that consent
acquiring a connection up to their
boundaries that can can ensure some
greater permeability through the site
in terms of the access plan so this is
the 839 Junction that both of these
Junctions will become left in left out
[Music]
um
and then we have the The Junction work
spot the onto North or into Abington
Road which is that the is in the eastern
Junction could be Morton Morton Lodge
and the proposed build out option so
this shows how there would be a footwear
provided on that sort of tight bit of
road as shown here we do have an overall
option but if this development comes
forward
and the budget wood scheme has not been
granted consent and have not come
forward this would be the preferred
option however if at future time the
land on the other side of the road had
been developed and the alternative is to
provide pedestrian Crossing connecting
with The Pedestrian links on that side
the condition 11 requires confirmation
of which which of those options to
achieve pedestrian connectivity wouldn't
follow and those whichever of the third
would have to be in place prior to
occupational use commencing on the site
this is the Western Junction onto action
Road at the end of the dedicated right
turn in there would be pedestrian links
provided up to the Northwest boundary or
the site beyond the a39 bridge it would
then be for the the highway authority to
provide pedestrian links up to average
and that would then enable resident
developing to have a you know potential
in a statements
to just now summarize to the main
planning considerations have set out
um on the screen now and also covered in
detail in your agenda report just
running through each of them the
principle of development is acceptable
the slight benefits from an allocation
within other than being the development
that is being proposed within the
requirements of that that allocation
that comes within zero one
um that's a good provide a significant
component of that allocation requirement
in terms of character interference the
application is an outlines with no
detail in terms of layout and scale and
appearance it is reported by
atlantically impact assessment and the
overall harm is not considered to
significant
um and there are mitigation measures
that can be put in place in detail the
stage Highway consideration the highway
the highway authorities there is an
objection subjects to various conditions
and contributions things the Cure
um ecology environment again there are a
number of opportunity conditions to
secure further surveys on the
development of this scale that's going
to come forward over a significant
period of time which is appropriate to
require further surveys and snap to set
out by a condition biodiversity Net game
with Institute at 10 was a combination
of on and off-site provision
amenity impacts would eventually be
considered detail at the dead massive
stage in terms of Labor impact and
overlifting
Etc and there is a requirement for noise
assessment to ensure that any
development that comes forward can any
noise harm from the investment of the
state can be mitigating flooding and
drainage both water and the local Blood
Authority Arabian no objections subject
to conviction
Heritage and archeology
again no objections of archeology or a
factorified subject to a condition
um Heritage and it's the building
there will be a need to consider the
impact on wolves in the house that
Reserve map stage and the condition
um it would be necessary to ensure that
that layout is respected in that setting
but that is more for the detail change
in terms of infrastructure being the
agenda report that sets out all of the
respects that have been made from
barriers such as 2012 and what the
policy requirements are for the
development there is also a clearly
depended to your gender report the the
application meets all of those
infrastructure requirements is policy
compliance that suppose they're present
affordable housing and various other
planning obligations that have been
requested
and just moving on to the planning
balance
the the side to barricaded it's
considered that the same development we
do however can only operate in the
desire well we don't have a five year
language Society balance things
applicable
there are significant benefits
associated with this application not
least bringing forward a key allocation
within our plan and all of the
additional facilities and services that
go with it which meet both the needs of
the development but also provide wider
benefits beyond the boundary of the site
it's
almost
significant contributions to meeting our
five year land Supply and the harm that
being identified in your agenda report
is implementing there is less than
substantial harm to have Heritage assets
um landscape harm is identified that
it's your office of view that that quite
that nearly the benefit of your team
have way down and approving is
recommended subject to a legal agreement
and the condition set out in the report
foreign
contributions on this
I missed everything have beginning to
get the committee an office of present
to an introduce themselves so our
starting right outline comes with her
and I represent North award and I'll
remember over there good morning my name
is David mccoth and I represent bit of
the norm
morning my name is Peter Christie I also
representative Norm good morning my name
is Rosemary Locke and I represented two
rivers and three Wars
good morning Pennington represent
locally and puttford
morning Richard Wiseman I represent the
chevier and Landry Ward
thank you thanks for connecting you've
met Helen
Smith our planning managers
and then we've got the two-step facing
me
good morning I'm Sandra the committee
Park good morning I'm Tom banstein I'm
done with practice services manager
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
C with lavender
I would like to object to the planning
application for the following reasons
there were a number of new developments
in this area that have already been
built or due to be built giving
significant extra accommodation in this
area the roads and infrastructure cannot
support a large development
this proposed development will result in
a minimum of 1500 new residents that do
not appear to be any plans to increase
the numbers of doctored surgeries Dental
practices or additional police fire
ambulance and Hospital facilities
especially absent and emergency
facilities
on one recent ad hoc check wait time at
North Devon District Hospital a e was a
staggering 29 hours
on regular checks this doesn't normally
drop below four hours
how can this Council approve this
development which will just add more
pressure to an already struggling
infrastructure and could potentially
lead to someone losing their life
because an ambulance wasn't available or
they couldn't be seen properly at a e
we are continually being reminded about
the impact of climate change would the
amount of building work that is going on
in the in this area surely we should now
be protecting the areas between those
already approved housing developments
if we lose these natural wild areas we
will lose valuable valuable heteros
fields and trees along with this we will
lose the animals birds and insects that
are already struggling to divide around
the town of bit of birds
we want to try and Tackle climate change
we need to start by saying no to this
large development
the roads cannot cope with the potential
additional traffic and we already
approved housing Estates will generate
let alone these additional 750 dwellings
saying that the roads will be improved
in intermission you only have to drive
along amersham Road and see the state of
the Roadster by The Village Park estate
would I be writing saying that when this
development was approved promises were
made that the road will be upgraded and
maintained
the disruption will be the destruction
that will be caused by this new
development will be immense and last few
years
a wildlife that is living in this area
being displaced EG colonies of fats to
dirty roads large Vehicles damage in the
existing roads and the noise caused by
the heavy duty Machinery I believe this
will change the much loved area into a
place that people want to avoid I
strongly object to this development
foreign
ER Brothers
dear members of the planning committee I
would like to make the following
comments regarding the application for
the construction of 750 dwellings a 50
bed Care Facility local Center and
primary school at land north of the
aberton road in support of my objection
I live very close to the Atherton Road
and ever since the College Park estate
has been built the traffic on that
fairly narrow unwinding Road Anderson
Road and College Park towards the big
sheep those brackets has an increased
extensively
the car views when walking near the road
are already at a very toxic level which
is in doubt harmful
which is sorry no doubt horrible to the
health of residents and especially
children walking so nearby school from
both the Londonderry estate and the
College Park estate as well as the
surrounding areas
bearing in mind that the College Park
estate comprises of 232 houses plus a
care home this development of 750 houses
plus a care home will make the air
quality unbearable as the average
household has two vehicles
you must not forget that the further 290
dwellings are planned for the other side
of the road and the news or has already
been appealed we are potentially looking
at a further 2000 vehicle visiting this
tiny Road where the width of visibility
are very restricted in place of it and
the traffic is already an issue
who pays litigation for producing that's
been limited to 30 moles per hour at the
edge interested and exit to this the
estate will not make it safer in terms
of air pollution or possible accidents
the construction phase itself would
already put undue pressure or an already
damaged and substandard Road surface and
large Vehicles would be a wheel Hazard
as the road is just not wide enough
the proposed development side is classed
over the area of ancient Woodland
ancient trees and Veteran trees and this
precious space should be protected for
the benefit of wildlife generations to
come and air quality the fields should
be used for food production
[Music]
world life in that area is of high
importance and at high risk it is
currently a criminal offense to injure a
protected species like bats dormites or
to store their habitats
bearing in mind that the surveys were
carried out around 2011 and the College
of Parker state had since been built
which resulted in a severe reduction of
habitat the number of protective species
living in the development area have
likely increased substantially due to
the pavement
therefore it would be totally
unacceptable to use data that in over 10
years old and new surveys should be
carried out at an appropriate time of
the year for an accurate decision can be
made
as some digging has already commenced in
one of the fields the developer needs to
be reminded that any construction
without permission and licenses that
endangered protective species or their
habitats like tree Hedges Etc will be
stuffed up to a substantial fine and
even if imprisonment if taken to court
furthermore I would like to point out
that there are not enough facilities in
the area to accommodate a number of new
houses proposed the medical center in
the town are already struggling and not
Devon District Hospital which at one
point was considered for the closure of
a several Awards had waiting times at
AMA of over 24 hours in recent weeks the
number of people in planning sorry the
number of properties in planning are not
sustainable and without adequate
infrastructure it would be unacceptable
to potentially put lives at risk thank
you for listening
foreign
[Music]
West
[Music]
firstly what you to say thank you for
giving me the opportunities today
[Music]
this is a site that's allocated for
development in the north Durban foreign
[Music]
sometimes it's made of a call you've
previously resolved from information per
scheme not materially different from
that in front of me today that was back
in June 2016.
the latest development proposal requires
a tremendous level of work dialogue with
your offices and also colleagues from
Devon County Council
the applications now back before you
even follow-ups and support setting out
recommendations for Grant subjects
section 106 legal agreements we strongly
support that recommendation
we are pleased that if there's our lack
of discussion with your offices the
application is now able to offer a
political compliant 30 affordable
housing
this will result with delivery 325
audible homes which represents an
increase of over 105 pounds compared to
that Steve previously agreed from 2016.
The Proposal would also provide the land
without the contributions for a new
school
local Center sports open space provision
and a care facility
however the application will also be
cure a number of Highways and public
transport improvements alongside other
infrastructure contributions towards
education Sport and Leisure Library
services and Power
since the previous resolution France
we've also believed to be able to secure
through on-site Improvement and through
off-site financial contributions to the
north Devon bytes there a 10 net gain
biodiversity such a game is above and
beyond current policy refined
we're pleased to confirm that we've also
made good progress on the section 106
legal agreement to secure these
infrastructure and financial
contribution
you're committed previously recognized a
significant opportunity to presented by
the site to deliver much needed high
quality homes and will still Revenge the
case
given the clear benefits of these
proposals and the offices clear
recommendations we respect the request
that matters resolve to grow on the
Planning Commission should this be the
case if we expect to complete the legal
agreement by the end of the year
Nintendo
proposals in early 2023
today
thank you
that encourages speakers for this
application so I'll throw it out into
the committee start every day
so
yeah if you want to yeah
[Music]
I think you ought to come down because I
have a couple of questions
obligation
well it's not you can't explain as well
but one question I thought that I'll
start the ball rolling is this left in
the leftovers
um
[Music]
there
and traffic coming out from this big
development will have to turn that angle
to remember that why could not a
roundabout have been a small idea of
this church
when you travel about the country and
see these very much the link road range
we often have round boats on them
branching off by the commercial
Industries or hands instead Peter was
sending all the traffic habits and cross
roundabout that combined with what's
planned about its own today rules uh
they developed the kind of application
method
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
starting it
I can only have two links up of it into
the site so this that that forming more
of the junction is one large Junction
rather than simply the left and left out
that's this so this is what we're told
by the applicant and what we've
previously approved by committee that
we're interested in the last time
well I can't agree with it I think it's
a ridiculous idea that the junction
to explain the rest of it I mean you
think that the planning of the
obligations yeah so instead of the
section 106 agreements we've got numbers
on page 77 of the agenda regions um
there's there's two main aspects to my
request which is that the at least in
contribution for the bus services
[Music]
and have flexibility to be able to be
new on providing the improvements to who
we've heard around that so there's no
doubt that the level of growth being
proposed in the plan for a bit for the
northern
necessitates the meaning for I would
rather that to be upgraded capacity
um
basis and we've got group plans uh
through separate Planning Commission or
upgrading that we have submitted uh
proposal to Department of accountable
and received funding to improve that
along with Buckley Junction and worked
all the way along the north Devon road
towards South Mountain
um
the issue with this particular site
we have secured
just over a million pounds from
different planning sites around the area
how have we then received today very
recently two hundred thousand pounds the
rest of those contributions would come
from sites that could yet reached their
trigger and would be
seven to ten years away
so we at the present time we would not
be able to borrow money at the same rate
we could when we looked at these
contributions due to the change in
interest rates and the cost of the scene
itself is significantly increased in the
last few years due to leveraging
inflation we all know that that's a
general inflation but the civil
engineering terms that's
five percent
experience
so we will deliver Junction
it's at what point and call and when and
when it's needed
sooner rather than later would be
preparable but to be able to do that it
would be used without the flexibility
to use money from this site if it comes
forward before the other sites
and fill in any Gap that we might have
to be able to deliver it so I'm also
aware site was providing 30 affordable
housing which is not within my Arena but
this isn't something that has happened
on many sites of people and then move my
ability Report with this application
every day
or having an estimated leading to make
professional reading conclusions of what
we did towards
but another factor is that the current
situation regarding bus services
and may be aware of stage appearance are
reducing some services in accountable is
providing alternative route on some of
those Services
shouldn't want to be an adult in
Torrington
and the 21 Services were reduced that we
have from every 15 minutes to every 30
minutes between a little bit of Arsenal
and then the only connection to the
Western Helena will change from half
hourly hourly that has expected to
increase again in the summer however
even living in the area during the
winter you know the reduced bus service
so we what we do with the bus services
in the future is unknown on the level of
service is unknown the level of funding
means that the government is unknown
so we need
some flexibility and what we can spend
with single transport contribution on
additional buses and whether we even
want to provide more buses in the short
term for
a few years and then have to remove them
again because
so there's lots of issues we're all
surrounding funding which is a
nationalism at the moment being able to
have a flexibility to spend that I'll be
around that will be very interesting
thank you
affordable
it does deliver to 30 affordable
yes so
that's what that's what before you the
determination today so if a positive
resolution is made then the agreement
will will bind the applicant to
delivering 30 cents now the way that the
planning legislation works and we have
the planning Authority don't have to
accept any request to amend that within
a five-year period of that agreement
being signed
um so you know in our our gift to
decline to entertain it after a
five-year period we would have to
consider any requests that came in that
would be through a deep variation to the
legal agreement and that would need to
be reported by by any evidence we can't
stipulate at this point that we wouldn't
accept what we would have to accept any
application now within a five minute
period is that the council's discretion
as to whether we would accept and
consider any amendment that 30
affordable housing
um clearly if that's a significant
element of your consideration today in
terms of balance
um you know if a request came in within
that years it would be necessary to
consult with an animal certainly a board
members at the very least we could
consider an application to amend that
that 30 percent
um but it would most likely need to come
through committee come through members
um and like I said we wouldn't have to
entertain it I think if it were the very
line of reduction or a few percent it
would probably be unreasonable for us
not to consider such an application
um but it is an argument within a five
inquiry marketing
um
you at least in the beginning about the
seven to ten year
position
but from the council said that that's
what that's really you know it kind of
concerns me because the large event like
this seven Twins and obviously you're
not going to be building quick anyway
because you need to skew the markets
obviously so it's viable to sell sell
these properties to the you know
whoever's going to buy them because he
released them all at once you're going
to kill your marketing you're going to
kill your prices to actually maximize
your profit on it so we all we all
understand that but it's just a concern
seven to ten years you said 10 years was
North Devon District hours it was also
we share the same joint plan so I'm
hoping we're not like-minded to just go
along with them because they've had a
case come across where it's 10 years we
still dated seven what I'm trying to get
at is we always see the rejection in the
affordability a deformable houses uh you
know this is something that you know
they're basically selling it to us 30
affordable we're in a crisis where we
need to provide housing okay I I don't
think the national government level
whatever affordability is there's an
updated this committee but which I
provide this accommodation locally and
if we're losing accommodation because
they're glorified they said you get 30
that comes at the end goes back to 20
you know in terms of it it's a lot you
know even two friends it's super fast
deduction so how's the knee that we
actually we do need going forward yeah
um so I mean in terms of the the time
scale for implementing it
um the National Guard uh is that
anywhere councils can't demonstrate at
five Millions by courage a timely
delivery on how are they I think what
can make you need to appreciate this is
one of the biggest applications that
will come before you it is a significant
amount of development
um and it is to to you know increase
that time scale for submission seven
years with what we've sort of felt was
reasonable when you look at some build
out range
um and as a developer law homes are
obviously very experienced in
understanding how long something takes
to build out
um it is for submission of that last are
hunted
um you know it's open to community and
simple whether you feel 10 years is
reasonable or not
um we're being requested by the law that
tenure is would would help with delivery
in the sense of being able to phase it
over that period of time
um but you're obviously there's initial
suggestion with seven years
[Music]
is changed to 10 years then at what
stage with any of the sector 106 one is
being released that's going to delay the
release of any section 106 running so
that was one of my concerns and I've
also got a note about the 30 affordable
we all know generally what happens when
a full application is submitted they
come in with the liability assessment to
say that they can't afford to do that so
I'm somebody back up what counts for God
said that we do need someone's
performance structure for 30 and I agree
with what our officer has just said
um I see that really good to uncounter
what no objections to the application
and the conservation officer has got no
objections
um I know there are 45 objection letters
on the planet bottle but I picked out a
letter of support and these comments are
there is a real lack of Housing and
scores in Bedford and I feel that a lot
of objection comments are overlooking
this without considering the
consequences of having lots of small
aged children where no with nowhere to
go to school or have it overcrowded
stalls a Disney is 750 houses will be
added to the local market what
councilman office just then some young
people the chance to get onto the
housing market in an area that they have
lived in their whole lives especially
since the housing market has recently
been smashed appeases in this area
thanks and second homeowners and Steve
increases and prices so that is just one
General company Republic support
it is
I'm sure many other counselors and what
things to say but I would like to
propose that the applications approved
subject to the amendment to those two
conditions
thank you councilman
cancer Christie yeah thank you um
well this is in the local plan which I
didn't vote for
um
I've I vote against this originally back
in 2016 because it squeezes bideford
East West we've got
given the analogy of a toothpaste being
squeezed out you've got this long thin
part of benefit there having said that
um it has been voted on before the
section 106's are very interesting uh
councilman bushby and I were invited
along to look at section 106's I think
we're invited as chairman and vice
chairman of torridge and they are quite
impressive I have to say uh and being
pragmatic it has been voted on before
and I know it's going to be accepted
um what I should have problems with and
there'll be four aspects you know I'd
like uh officers to answer each one as
they go through but in school
because there is a letter on our website
the dated July of this year from the
chief education officer of Devon and it
says to mitigate the impact of this
major allocation a new primary school is
required black and white
in fact if you look at the section 106's
Devon County are getting about 3.9
million pounds from this development
plus says the money is from the
development to the south of Covelli Road
have we had anything from Devon County
telling us when they are going to build
that school
um so
with the education side of things we
have
um a site that was consented to the
staff of Covelli Road as well so I think
that came before committing
um earlier this year and this would be
an alternative site option that the way
the local education authorities have
considered both of these sites in
whichever comes forward first with the
web sort of zone now we do have regular
dialogue with the education Authority
that ultimately what if this is approved
and
understanding
neighborhoods decide which
there's also in schools like within
Northern as well which has been secured
as part of David and the Davenport
with recent information we've had from
the education Authority is that in terms
of cohorts and
um which is the people admission number
within business those numbers are
actually dropping due to the falling
bear grades and how that followed
through to the point of children
starting school so for example the
people admission admission number of all
the schools that are around this area
were total in any one year capacity
um is 2310
um and that's the the total number of
people that each School the admission
numbers in total is 330. now over the
next few years and the figures I've got
go up to 2025
that admission number dropped to 250
against a capacity of 330. so the local
education Authority are forever
monitoring and checking the situation
and clearly the impact of the
development of this sale combined with
the other big developments that are
coming forward are going to have an
impact on small and small bases the
exact timing of the school is out of our
hands at the local Authority it's it's
for us to secure that potential critical
fight to come forward and there are a
few options in here the exact timing of
when that school is going to be built we
I don't have a date for you we have not
been given that information from the
local education Authority and it would
be very much dictated by this sort of
changing picture in terms of that need
that capacity and the pupil numbers
um but certainly through this
application should it be approved the
the section 106 would would seek to
sure that 1.7 hectares of land and for
that to come forward in an early phase
of development so that we have done
everything we can as a local panel
authority to make that land available my
understanding is that this site is
preferable to the staff at the very very
sites which does benefit from Reserve
maps of permission to further down the
process
um that I I don't have an answer in
terms of when that school will be built
because we haven't been given that
information
thank you I hope our County councilors
take that on board
um
just one aspect of this uh if the school
is built here
um I have referred earlier to the the
problems of the estate to the south of
Camellia Road how are the children going
to get across to this estate uh perhaps
Matt Collins might like rather than
pouring more money into the bottomless
pit that is Haywood Road roundabout that
will achieve absolutely nothing perhaps
he might look at building a bridge
across here or moving the one in
basketball which is you know never used
uh moving down here because we are going
to need something like that and I think
we need to look at that anyway my second
Point
um the biodiversity is 120 000 pounds
from this site going off-site if you
combine that with the 120 000 pounds
from grad worthy which is going to
amishim which didn't sit very well and
breadworthy people
um that's nearly a quarter of a million
pounds and yet I've got no idea where
it's going just abyshire and I find that
really odd I'd like more details on that
from the biosity as possible because I
seem to remember when Andy Bell came and
talked to us this is a private land
owner who apparently had no duty to make
it open to the public or anything and
we're giving them a quarter of a million
pounds from this chemical there's a
section 106 money will come to us and
then we pass it on I I really do want to
know more about this because
it is it's very odd that public money is
being funneled off to a private
individual and yet the counselors who
are sending the money don't know
anything about it
um the third point I like to raise is to
drainage because Corner are gender on
page 57 it's going to be a combination
of surface basins and attenuation tanks
can I ask who's going to look after
those after this stays built is it going
to be Southwest water is it going to be
a private management company
my understanding Council Christine but
it would be Southwest water we would we
would take that on at the appropriate
stage of the development and it would be
deductible in that sense
um system
um the the condition the condition
that's been recommended by Ludwig and I
believe I find that there is an element
of that conversation
um just dying there
so condition 24 within your agenda
report filled with surface water
requires the gate seat on drainage
scheme when we come forward as part of
the reserve matters and also detailed
the table for the Management Service
water and still runoff as well and but
then at Point C it requires proposal for
the doctor and maintenance of the
permanent surface water drainage system
um completely there is evidence there is
agreement and for instance in Southwest
water so
that is something to be determined but
my understanding is that removing
elements of it that would be adopted by
Southwest launcher but that would come
out in the details day and once we have
the subject scheme so thank you can you
bear that in mind that application comes
forward so I will ask again because I'd
much rather it was to
our Core Body runs on private company
that is very small and the fourth Point
again it's actually about Southwest
water because
um there seems to be a contradiction
here on page 41 of our agenda and I just
figured out and said you don't need to
go to it
um it says uh
where is it uh
there seems to be a problem
um with the um foul sewage about the
size of the pipes and that yeah on page
65 it says there are no objections
without but clearly there's something
there but you may recall a recent
council meeting I did ask what's the
carrying capacity the Cobra sewage plant
which we've never been able to find out
Southwest water will not tell us and yet
here we are talking about the biggest
single
development in torridge
and yet we don't know if
Southwest water can actually really
handle that amount of sewage because
we're all aware that surcharging of the
sewage system during period of heavy
rain which you just had of course
um is pouring sewage into our Coastal
Waters and into the Estuary
I did ask at the last council meeting it
was passed that we write to South as
well we've been asked about it is and
I'm afraid although I think the
developers have actually been very good
they've been oh backwards to meet our
demands I'm afraid I cannot support this
at the moment until I know about
Southwest water because Southwest water
you know one hesitates to form a load of
cowboys but they do seem to get away
with a lot of problems uh we're all
aware I think that you know they're
they've been
um attacked by the uh is it awkward or
off what whatever they call themselves
but they're not meeting their
requirements the last 10 years and yet
here we are saying oh yes you can do
another 750 houses and yet that could
lead to more pollution
and I want to know just what Southwest
water I'm doing about this and are they
can they actually tackle this can they
uh can they appoint a cornrows and it
actually
resolve this problem
just quickly pick up on two things and
the biodiversity Council entity
um additional information
there
um
[Music]
Quantum had land that and what that
happens outside would be
it didn't go so far to give me a site
location or a site plan so unfortunately
I don't have that additional information
for you the north Devon biosphere would
have been bound into this agreement
together with the land owner for 30
years on southwards water and the
drainage so it is the case that no
objections are being raised they do your
correct bladder a requirement for
discussions to take place in terms of
being specifications and connection
point and signs of piping and that's as
you would expect in their role of
statutory under paper that would be a
separate profession that would take
place as a developer they are sort of
Duty bounds and separate legislation to
provide
through about their Ridge board
development
and we are being told by them in a
formal consultation response that they
are able to do that so from a planning
point of view
um we have no reason to question that on
the face of it but I do know what you're
saying about requiring
requesting more information in terms of
that more strategic picture in them
funding exactly how they're achieving
that
but I think that would sit outside of
the planning process at the moment
sorry don't just come back I think it's
actually Central to the planning process
because uh sewage if you've ever had it
in your street or around your houses
you'll know
how terrible that is
um and Southwest water actually not have
a good track record they've told us
before but you know oh no problems and
yet we're all aware of problems but I
take on board what is it
yeah just to pick up on the counselor
because I do agree with him on the issue
that Sacred Water and the lack of detail
that they give us on planning
applications
uh on page 41 as you referred to did say
that correspondence exist in in 2018
with Southwest water regarding the
public suicide to accommodate the
battlefield due to the development I
know that this refers to 750 homes and
does not
automation flow from a 50-day care
facility the local sense that when a
private school is wrong
the advice contained an email that was
known as the performance
so you know we really need to know that
there is capacity we can I will
mentioned that at recent meetings
National Anis is concerned about what's
being done in our represent things by
water companies
and we know that West Middle
on many occasions it put Barrel students
and then walked out here onto the
barrels and it is an acceptable but they
never tell us anything about capacity
and I think we should get a lot more in
our planning applications on capacity
and Tech responsible
with a capacity at cornbread and have
another thousand houses or five hundred
ounces or whatever but nothing will just
take the guy in The Compassion God we
don't know because we with all the
increasing sewage in the system when you
do have a rain for an incident now
that's going to exhausted the problem in
many areas certainly in Westwood Oregon
so I mean I agree there's no other
information
can I I should have said it before I
I've only just realized I'm dual-headed
on this I'm chairman of the Town Council
hiring committee and we have all the
discusses
um but I am dual hattadon thank you that
comes with Pennington
thank you chair uh I Echo the comments
about the viability issues
um just on page 61
um the first bullet point of the page
reported he was looked at the previous
application
um and it says that goes on to say um
there's been a huge change even since
this report has been written does that
still stand that's my press point I
would like to ask yeah okay so
I think
it's reference to what happens when the
application was considered before at
that time the applicant was
submitting a viability to be tested in
the district value and reviewed that and
out of that process it was deemed that
the development could only provides 16
affordable housing yes now we only
require that exercise to take place in
what's being paid in less than 30
percent
um the applicant is now saying they will
deliver and provide 30 on this site so
you don't need to retest the the
viability with the district value act so
that is sort of out of date that's
that's Elemental bit however that was
the position in 2016. just to come back
is that liability more at risk though in
the light of the events of the last 10
days basically the previous thing that's
where I'm coming from right okay
um that would be for the law to form a
view on that I mean we are being told
the committee of you know being told
that they can deliver policy compliance
scheme National guidance said that if
that says if that is the case in the
application that was put forward under
basis then as a planning Authority we
assume it to be viable we don't ask for
policy compliance to be demonstrated
um
it is ever-changing at the moment
viability positions as the community
know
um market conditions are changing all
the time at this precise point in time
we don't have an updated liability and
we couldn't require one to demonstrate
that 30 is okay
no then um second layers you're I'm a
rich chair uh page 40 I was interested
in the nhx one of six numbers
there is a minus 5000 under capacity for
the medical center and let me quite see
that there could be an argument before
that there's no need for the 386 000
contributions for GP facilities
um at the very end of the report
um
isn't going to be used this GP money the
396 000.
um is it going to be an on-site a local
facility within the area or is that
going to be an addition to business
medical center who already are under
capacity
um from the point of view and also it
doesn't bear which is time maybe people
who are registered with the different
Medical Center sometimes who find it
difficult to get any answers when they
ring up in the morning
um so there's a reality in these figures
I find I would like to dig deeper but
I'm not going to think today but how is
the 396 going to be used in the light
that there's only capacity
Medical Center
yeah so the way the NHS would look at
um GP provision within this area those
three surgeries the catchments featured
them overlap but they do look at them as
a combination so that that's the
position at the moment that there is
current capacity across all three
when factoring in the new development
and the population from it there then
becomes an issue and that's how they
start with calculating now how that
money will be spent the legal agreement
would require it to go towards
enhancement for deeply practices within
the geographical area now that there is
permission in place for enhancement to
know them surgery they're in the
consented scheme there that is an option
indeed there is an option for
an on-site Community within the local
Center however at this point in time we
don't know what how it would be spent it
would be the nhf to do that under the
terms of an Indian agreement but it is
to mitigate that increased population
that we take
that capacity
um under capacity to being above the
classification thank you
just one more Point uh highways um
thanks Matt for being here I think doing
a very good report
um declare if you're happy I suppose
because looking Butler of my award
contains a building for admission which
is only about 150 yards up from the
bridge and the other side of the
junction
um highway to receiving a contribution
to other two Villages I read the reports
to do improvements to from footwears and
access does that include all the way up
to the center of abortion Village
or is it just stopping on the boundary
average by that very narrow bridge
that's just the middle of the big Shield
um because that is quite a pinch point
that people sometimes particularly when
leaves are happy on the trees and the
bones and the trees are laying down two
cars coming together and we'll be
closing at quite a speed 60 mile an hour
that they're doing within the speed
limit and many cars don't keep within
the speed limit sometimes unfortunately
is the proposal for Highway improvements
on footway improvements all the way to
center of Hamilton Village
[Music]
I have an involved I had previously had
an informal discussion with me
about possibly using some land to go
around the bridge with it
[Music]
because my concern two points here when
you look at the the debt housing I will
show actually becomes a center of
population two reasons to school
um there is a pub
and you're going to be risky mornings
and evening with children going to
school because they probably may choose
to go to African school and I tried to
think what might be happening if
somebody was walking home taking a
shortcut across the main road with a
dark night so are you making good
provision
um should somebody decide to come out
and look directly across the 839 to walk
up to amateur little dark evening it
would be good lighting when I take them
that's something we would look at in the
in the detailed design yeah
um so yeah I definitely yeah the reason
that we need to make is still in the pub
well I just clarified Life Institute
chairs with our solution Perry can I
come back on this Reserve letters and
make some points on these do I have that
right to come back and because it's not
my ward actually in this development but
it does affect people that you use will
use this area do not have a right
um to come back for Reserve months if I
pulled in favor of this situation I can
answer that Council Pennington so
but way works from the 839 Bridge up to
Avid gym
um what what this application is Will
secure is a financial contribution
towards those work the red lines the
application doesn't extend along the
suburge but it doesn't it doesn't fall
apart it doesn't fall within the red
line so it would be a financial
contribution to the highway Authority
which I believe would be a trigger point
or prior to occupation or 200 dwellings
and the sum is 250 000 pounds now that's
how how that team comes normal record
wouldn't form part of our Reserve
massive application because it's outside
of the red line it's often by
improvement work and Matt may be able to
comment on how that process works from
the beginning theme point of view in
terms of consultation so as we
Progressive design
um we will use local member and under
general public on the details of that
supported business but go back to us
again so we have some input from that
point of view thank you chair for
Lamborghinis thank you and
what we're only average
I noticed the trigger point is that the
occupation of 200 dwellings
whereas the new vehicle in the junction
onto the Infinity home worked by the big
sheep Junction is after 100 miles so for
me it's far more important that the
Abbington Road improvements has done in
conjunction at the same time as that
Championship was 200 dwellings might not
happen to Earth
in their response there should be it
should happen quicker than that and I
mean
the same as the junction
and they that that thing could be
discussed as part of the negotiation on
perception when they fix
um I think what what members and indeed
officers need to be mindful of this is
viability in the dental Development
coming forward so you can't front load
all of your obligations it's making sure
that things are recently fans
um what the section 106 is currently
being looked at and if there's a
positive resolution today I imagine
there would be then if they're releasing
so it's certainly something that we can
we can discuss with the applicants if
that can be brought forward I think you
know that phasing and that trigger does
would still need to be justified the The
Pedestrian link work link going towards
bideford that prior to any occupation I
think that is where you would expect
most residents from the new development
to be wanting to travel
um I think it's less significant in
terms of occupation toward that action
but it's clearly a benefit development
so if you're happy chair we could we
could look at the fridge
and I think a lot of people would be
coming from this perspectives
development towards the average
indirectly then we should have a safe
way of moving and picking up Council
Penningtons pointed out in our religion
the answer that was given you could use
it wrote a book right around that legit
from
[Music]
so the the outline
um section 106 will propose heads of
terms
the really it really hinges on the
affordable element being stand on and as
you've said Helen once this is signed up
that there is then we cannot we all
didn't put inside me and and let's swing
unless we again
so that would secure it then sorry uh
we're waiting quite a while yeah yes I
just wanted to say that my questions
have been answered by other answers
particularly
um we went about the school I couldn't
have certain things about the NHS we
know it all looks good on paper it's
just it methodology
they can be quite different but they're
in all of mine I'd like to Second cancel
that
thank you councilor Brandon the final
thing I'll mention on this current
division it does today I think Council
quickly alluded to that
um
there is definitely
submitting at the impact of this major
allocation and new primary school is
required
no what other school role may be of it
and you're around to Heaven about what
we've had in your education I thought it
said don't go walk with me because it
takes time to actually designed motor
school and to say we're all right for
the next few years there's a capacity in
our stores
[Music]
[Music]
um
not challenging about I'm still not
happy about the junction with the big
sheep I think there's a catalani skills
me that there we are
okay it's been moved that we approve
this subject to that moment
cancer Chris can I ask if you vote for
this are you voting for Matt to become
flexible
on the Hayward roundabout
that's not even mentioned anything
and it comes and uh Naval transportation
[Music]
obviously I mean it is the only thing
will be and I've always supported and
I'm a characteristic the proposed cycle
where the Footwear through from Villages
Following part of the real railways
is it's a landowner which being a bit
not wanting to play ball and that is if
that doesn't happen because of that
handle on it then the money that is uh
but I wouldn't like it to see because it
is a button
and I thought as in adopt you told me it
was like to be started to the
improvements
projected for the end of this year I
think it's been pushed back now because
of the interest rate Etc and inflation I
think we're looking at probably March
next year that everybody would work
should be convincing on that but prior
to that which I did say you'll normally
don't catch me again the my the main
priority of the Democrat accounts would
be a safety eye class is my placement
the safety of the improvements of
Buckley Junction and by Heron's lead
widening those rows at first because
before we get anything around about or
any more infrastructure any more develop
that large events coming through these
small little pockets have to be widened
it out and make safe for the public
okay guys this is your auto accounts
meeting not at your family meeting here
I have mentioned on your planning
meeting about every round about four
yeah all right thank you right it has
been removed from the second moved back
here so long second
without this application
yes thank you chair thanks for the
voting for councilor Brown
councilor Christie against
councilor leather or excellent look or
councilor mcgov or councilor Pennington
or against the winesman
that's 74 and one against chair thank
you
yeah yeah
I mean
[Music]
thank you chairman um for those of you
that don't know me so
um Chrissy following reminder Council
um this is not taken for our line
management and all matches
the devil and the case officer is then
importantly can't be here today
um so I've got the uh later of present
in this one uh next slide please
um this is like a paper plan as you can
see it's an aerial plan
um that's agricultural uh it's like a
question and there's a small question
building on the site and the student
report scenes like this side and the
highways to the South next privately
uh this is aerial photos of the site so
it is in the uh Countryside for
approximately 0.5 miles from uh the
maintenance of pole service
[Music]
uh this is an addictive sort of plan
um there's uh if you're in two dwellings
uh with their area or uh export pool
enhancements and terrible which will
provide above for the kids
slide
um a series of photos
uh you can see the typical weathering
holdsworthy and that's all going
distance
um there's the mainland the right of
that so that's that Noble leads the West
complete sorry
this uh Pedro boundary in the bottom
corner there once the site there's no
Barber side to the west and then the
existing entrance and building on site
going there and it's like these
uh again since
um
[Music]
um these are the two considerations
um
the opposite is recommending approval
um the site is technically just come
through uh it's expectable to
um of the North Carolina
however
um who considerates both important we've
been proposed early and the services
which hold the offer being one of our
student Senators uh concluding
um
facilities to Market store quality
petrol stations or Services the right of
employment
um and it's a short walk from there
that's considered on the site with
sustainably located to
um
have considered to outward benefits and
uh address will have a recommendation of
approval for you
um back to impair to
[Music]
we've got um
one speaker for this application which
is um Darren sure things before it
created
if you'd like to come up to the
microphone thank you how many seconds
and then if you speak right into the end
of that American football season picture
doesn't matter thank you my name is
[Music]
the application uh many thanks to the
opportunity to discuss this today
um as we just heard from the senior
officer they recommendation and viewed
me as one of approval
um based largely on the back of the the
five year land Supply issue went to the
torrid and joints and seven local plans
backward Basin uh with that obviously at
the 21 is apparently engaged with States
within the in such circumstances
development must be considered outside
of development settlement boundaries
um
the slides the site is closely related
to hold of the um our services within
um and in the officers uh
report for the for the committee today
it does uh discuss the um the sort of
principles surrounding the lack of the
five-year land Supply
um and that yeah the need to you know
the SP 21 policy
um you know they can sites like these
outside of development boundaries
um you know considered
um the application is is an outline
um and all matters are reserved that the
officers do
um summarizing The Proposal combined
with the main policies with everything
plan
um there's been very different objection
to the proposal I think it's been one
excuse me one public objection and I
believe it's time to call them
um the site does fall within an area
surrounded by other existing relevant
reforms have been some other recent
um approvals not far from Josephine
Safety Lane actually bought us a
reduction of winterland Lane I think
things two approvals down down that road
which are probably 200 yards away from
this site without recent approvals
um there was a concern initiative
regarding uh means of uh found water
disposal however that's now been agreed
with the environment through the
suitable practices being carried out and
really just to sum up the the
application is not aside for dense
housing via by large developer besides
privately owned by a local retired
couple countdown and they're looking to
secure you know sustainable attention to
give the years while making that
available for depression of two family
homes in an area that is supposed to
related to the specific expensive and
that's really all I was going to say
thank you okay thank you for your
contributing
all right that's the end of the week
probably contribution
discussion on this one
cancer
yeah I was in one objects the state of
the development is only 17 meters on
this bearing place can you confirm that
Grizzle
Jonathan and that
yes
is the line is 25 meters when we're
walking to the science of that first
wedding so
um implying terms that's a countable
distance to reward any adverse amount of
impacts and
um
so it's not 17 meters as per the
objection number it depends where it
takes 17 meters from I I don't know
um where he's taking that from but if
he'd open that rear boundary wall to the
to that Center Line will sort of show
your head sure
then that's 25 meters so the [ __ ]
humans in this difference between the
balance between law and events so maybe
70 meters it can take it from Matthew
but this this out all separation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
own confirming issue for resilience
cancer crispy yeah well I thank Council
dependent for pointing that out it's
very interesting right
um what I looked at I looked at this on
Google Earth but I don't understand and
I see in our agenda it's half a mile
from holdsworthy and your parents is
well related to holdsworthy walking
distance
and I think wait a minute that's not if
this wasn't a five-year land strike we
wouldn't even be looking at this because
it is right in the middle of the open
Countryside and if I sit here and I know
we don't work on precedents if I sit
here and I think oh half a mile where
are they half a mile over there to put a
house because it's well related it
doesn't make any sense I'm sorry but at
the same time what council Pennington's
just raised is I think I think it's
Germaine for this planning application
to get a local means housing and then
try to squeeze into open market housing
next to it because you've just got your
local news housing it doesn't sit very
well
I'm not entirely sure that's a question
but I can answer uh Rich
um so yeah I would prefer if we didn't
have a Barbie house in night Supply we
would then would use it and find simple
people that sound type
um
Supply which leaves us to balance now uh
about starts up with something in favor
is
within proximity to a very sustainable
location between holes of it and I think
he said it's like a one minute drive or
seven minute walk or something and
obviously it depends someone if you walk
um the the key point is is that it's
it's possible with existing housing so
not not only is he saying the sites are
staying at all but actually it's
difficult to identify harm so
the harm that we would need to
demonstrate is significantly Dangerously
outweighed
because
of the skin being two values now because
it's within those clots of powders
there's not really any landscape harm
there's not really any harm from the
sustainability point of view because
it's about the world so I mean
um it's not such a scale that it it
would be
ridiculous in this location
um its location next to local need
sliding if anything it will reduce the
value of that local knee swelling and
make it more available so I think in
marketing
um in terms of effort in that game if
there's a Net game exactly doesn't
benefit
um
drainage is fine and so
when you come to formulate that isn't
refusal there's not really a sad one to
make you could potentially quite an
argue there
um because it isn't confide that that's
a policy who was in its own right but
um I think that that will be ability to
compare anyone who's starting from the
Tilted products so you're starting from
one percent of the favor and it's
entitled for similarities
okay now just come back and ask further
question which you may not be able to
answer now these are only two houses
against a five year announcement do we
have any figure for the number of houses
we have to find
[Music]
[Music]
the problem is is that they're not being
built out so we have to allow more and
hope that they are are then being built
out in a timely manner so it's not
necessarily finding Supply it's just
trying to get a smaller size bill that
effectively so that we can show that
it's then this is the difference of
councils we can't force people to build
stuff out we can simply improve our
patrons which we have to presume and get
filter
um the fact that there's only two
um with limits
positive lives in schemes but much more
into here probably wouldn't be
acceptable because inside and far apart
thank you could I just cancel it then we
just said we might get a figure later
this year
by the end of this year
yeah I'm happy to quickly update on that
so a lot of work being done at the
moment interview establish
um whether we do or don't provide the
plans to buy
um I think today the the agenda for the
next planning quality committee has been
published and there is a paper within
that agenda which summarizes the current
program for the housing and economic
land availability assessment and a big
part of that work overlapped with
dividing Answers by calculation and the
program that is set out in that now
publicly available document indicates
February as a date they're seeking to
calculate recalculate whether that
calculation is that we do or don't have
a Bible understand we won't know until
that point but that's that's the time
this year we're wearing looking at both
times and routines and bank accounts
have been working already
I think I mean I've always said
personally it's a nonsense it's going to
be a housing Alliance Supply condition
uh and it's called No endless problems
with this
committee and the authority and threat
to come to because
where we have development boundaries
because we've not got this so-called
Pioneer Supply
[Music]
within a nearby distance which half a
mile the roles were the center of this
end and I wrote at the top of my my uh
report here that the principle of
development in this location is the
issue and as Chris has said if we still
had that idea how did land Supply which
was no real control over we give
planning permission and if we don't get
no if it makes sense Supply but because
we haven't done it we've got to consider
this so-called I'm saying this in the
room where we don't know where it is
and the presumption is in favor of
development unless that development is
serious to damage the area or have you
know serious implications for the area
um
um
on page 85 the honors and Stage it is
considered that the future occupies on
the site because access to various
Services
I think I like taking a short car
Journey which is about 0.5 miles I
believe bear that in mind for later at
the agenda
um I think
by approvement in these smaller
applications you are more likely to get
houses built quicker and on the open
market that people can build and what we
approved earlier on 750 yeah it might
take 10 years to get up under the houses
whereas why approving applications like
this you will be helping local people by
houses so I will seconds cats and
letters recommendation of approval
this
right I I recommend the approval of
Garrison lock setting it can you check
the book please
yes thank you chair cancel about two
four cancel the brown thanks to Christy
councilor leather for councilman
or thanks for Pennington or cancer
Wiseman
thank you unanimous chair thank you
all right our next application
application
seven speed on pages 19 seconds only few
playing fields that they even know this
application is always
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you um
[Music]
in this day
this is the regular attention plan uh
just for instance relationship uh it's
important things in the middle uh
[Music]
next slide
slide
[Music]
and again a site plan during the uh
where the extension is located
[Music]
next item
uh these are some section drawings
um
[Music]
contextual uh
and these are the main kind of
considerations
[Music]
thank you
thank you Ryan that was very great thank
you right we've got one speaker this
application
uh Johnny Stevens
what she said I told you've got three
minutes to address the commitment down
here
hello my name's Sam I'm the chairman of
the football club I could go with these
18 months ago
um act we've got Bowl hit in 2017 with a
lot of interest in order
um when I took over it was our two UT
um and the main goal of taking over the
club was to get more than a football
club and involved the whole Community uh
so two aspects of it on the bit and off
the pitch I'm in that short 80 months
we're now going to buy you've been your
adult teams and two disabilities
[Music]
all different body able-bodied
um
and you know on in terms of one pitch
um to increase our increased growth
being desperately the disabled data
um currently
[Music]
yeah available
[Music]
um and the building itself was 40 years
old out of the top so it was made for
overall Improvement of protecting the 18
months we incorporated a local food
pantry
um that started out during over by yeah
[Music]
that's where and rapidly now
in a week
residing over the covers in the building
so
um
the extension would be for them to hold
a full-time country there
um we also agreed that with a nighttime
Landing spotless which we really want to
start with the second one in there
um the local BMX Club Boxing Club and
also we saw the world and
um we let the companies get the
fireworks we can get in so that's on and
off the pitch of what we need um
contribution
it comes from the goal yeah I think this
was Jim at that first of all I need to
declare that I'm a an honorary trustee
at the Bollywood Center itself I say it
would be an open mind I'm not an
official trustee they're just not very
positioned I I do hope that um I don't
do a straight so clean up the mic for
myself I'd like to go straight into uh
approving this application for uh vote
for approval on this from there the work
that they've done at the what they'll
show me it's like there's absolutely
fantastic and it's a benefit to
community and then the data the the
situation we face now Community Spirit
you know it's coming back into Chamois
now and you're staying to Mrs Stevens
and his team there and to see the club
which went to nothing but actually faded
away and those re-lit the torch again
and it's putting sharing back on the map
again to me it's it's a proven the area
as well it needed Improvement for a long
long time and this only complements it
so I'm in full support
I'll second that
um the Town Council we pass this
unanimously uh all in favor so yeah
great
well nobody else wants to come to me I
mean there was no sound
thank you thanks for the mountain
that's the brown boy
that's the Pennington or Pennsylvania or
unanimously approach
you move on then
flight item 70 the airplane applications
here on pages 97 to 107. so right in
your 100 sure
cancel that obviously difficult
everything dress our world speakers of
all the members I am going to leave the
floor that the committee and joined as a
member of the public thank you
foreign
[Music]
and here's some error images again to
indicate this format which is located to
the west from Southwest
0.7 miles from
Dalton and the sort of access to the
Eastern options or the bus services
[Music]
again an error image again just to
indicate the surroundings and
surrounding contexts
again we continue to sort of temporary
nature
and here's some images of the site so in
the top left we've got a new result on
the road and looking towards the
application site and that sort of
inclusive foreign
[Music]
and this is a view from that access so
we have a new uh East
um towards the combustion
approaching for and then again
[Music]
the nearest series of images that can
attached from the route from the
applications
particularly important to note the
infrastructure within this group
some sort of traditional sort of Devon
will relate people related but also used
to
um and humidity like footpath and
Licensing provisions
[Music]
and this is a cyclone sort of zoomed out
to show the visibility's names
Department
and they zoomed in image just showing
the uh when dwelling purpose
now you can sort of see the rock outline
of that big barn there
was parking and also land segment
although this plan is addictive
money considerations
I'll just quickly run through I might
considerations I've been inside within
the general report
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
located so even though it is 0.7 miles
to an adult in itself which has a
limited but except for rental services
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
though
[Music]
um
the application
policies in terms which relates to
ensuring that they have sequences for
actors promoting the previous
installment generates in terms of the
access towards doctors
[Music]
and in terms of great
um the application
that the officer is satisfied that they
found drainage continuously
um
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
in terms of the current balance
and there is a lot of benefit associated
with uh
[Music]
that would be used against a significant
contribution
[Music]
there is no policy intensive spoilers
[Music]
thank you
one who runs
if we've got two speakers
so there's the first one is um the
applicant parents Harrison Jennings
a virtual setup about three minutes to
give you a presentation
thank you
firstly I would like to take this
opportunity to thank you all for your
time and patience today as we discussed
the development of the path and a yard
I'd like to begin by introducing myself
hello my name is Harrison I'm 23 years
old I've lived in development a village
in which I have lived in my whole and
loved my whole life I attended Dalton
Primary School alongside both my brother
and sister and have lived in the same
family home throughout my life
I've always worked locally to Dublin
starting at vegan garage where my
parents were only a mile outside the
village I now run my own buy wooden taxi
business employing 18 local people
during the past couple years I've been
selling firewood to the local community
a business in which has grown substantly
and predicted to expand greatly due to
the current price increase of electric
and heating oil
this business is now located at the plot
of land of which I own I have any yards
we're running the business that happened
here it has given me the opportunity to
opportunity to expand and burden my
plans with firewood
alongside these plans moving out in the
family Zone the student which is
currently being held back due to the
available and affordable housing within
the local area
a barrier which has increased greatly
over the years for first-time buyers
therefore I'm hoping to build upon the
lab that have plenty yards so I'm able
to settle and start my own family with
my partner who I've been with for seven
years
my partner's grown up locally and is
currently undergoing teacher training
within that Open Primary School I'd love
to My Future Families to be able to grow
up in the same Village and surrounding
local communities now
I am not looking to build in the middle
of nowhere there are other dwellings
within the facility some of which are
written in today in support of my
application I feel what I'm trying to
achieve that into the equipment
candidate properties in the area
I've already enhanced the area since
I've actually dropped it properly by
removing a direct debt and replacing it
with a perfect built building for my
business
I have also created a new entrance for
the property which is about the
Improvement visibility for me and the
traveling the road
both of which went through the planning
process last year
there is currently a double bar in the
corner of the site which is on view from
the road I already have Water and
Electric on site for the impact of the
surroundings would be minimal and if I'm
successful with the application it may
be a replacement to create my family
home which would further enhance the
area
with the potential that they are being
my future family favorite creating a
safe environment within the supportive
Community is extremely important to me
within recent years I've played and
sponsored the local football team and
often watch their matches as well as
this over the past three years I've
volunteered as the local snowball of
Rowan which I hope to carry on for many
more years
I truly appreciate this opportunity and
hope you can be sympathetic to my needs
and support me and my future plans thank
you thank you thank you thank you
in our next speaker
and Council Rock who is speaking as the
world member of the Dome
all right speakers won't Bender informs
the board of this application you would
have seen from our Zoom slightly last
month although as our local plan and the
term Indio you would have seen that
within the curse as a new agriculture
erected from the African Authority
business and one of the benefits of this
application was that it made the access
for an egress to the site except for in
Highway terms
buildings
designers located 0.7 miles per second
village golden is the Brighton Village
we have a church chapel storm a vibrant
Village
forward with both of Institute public
houses the football team and a large
well equipped children's play area
I really do not know
the authors are always overdated nearby
as it doesn't
contains the services
or two vehicle with and even at the
right line down the center of it
this statement is absolutely not correct
golden is part of the root of the main
service by being
we have eight double-decker buses a day
in engine
that this service is from exit Advanced
all five times and benefits there's the
best of it though Beacon and the bus
stop if rectory Road does not went five
miles away from the application sites
and this service will continue which
they'll be confirmed by then County
Council two days ago in the region of
the past services
we talked a lot about maintaining the
vibrancy of town centers this statement
also advised the many of our abilities
we must encourage the younger members of
our community who have been born and
brought up in such than it is they're in
Maine to ensure the future of Our
Vintage storms and our businesses our
right move developed and there are three
properties priced over 500 000 pounds
three at 400 to 450
000 over to 175 300
000.
and yes the one we've added at the 650
000.
so to remain in the village when you
grew up and as it is building a lot of
his home on land that he owns is the
only option of the African
doesn't get the highway with no
objectives the Environmental Protection
Officer has no objective and subject of
the construction now submission
and Golden Bears countable support
provided that it remains illegal means
dwelling and that is an important
consideration there are no objective
Matters from the two near neighbors
there are four evidence of support on
the planet or one of which is wrong
events that the large white housewife
directly opposite the application Style
the application the st01 dm01 dn24 s210
and dm05 and use them until the balance
argument that benefits greatly outweigh
any items identified in fact the
obviously it is important status in 3A
that it would not significantly not on
the immediate in the very neighboring
properties
consideration
[Music]
what I do find convicted is that an at
the cage of 10135 which we've considered
earlier on the planning officer said it
is considered that future occupy the
desire for that access to various
Services it holds if I take a picture
in this application the office and said
that is one of the individuals
conditions
so I ask you the committee to support
this application subject to the
important conditioning for it to remain
a local feed swelling and a suitable
Construction in our management plan
thank you
thank you Council result
[Music]
I'm going to say read I've got to say
reading through the report
um
the protections being recommended
conditions stipulating that the dwelling
is uncivilage to the neighboring finger
business
uh
and the one we've considered the one
before last which we talk about plan
don't miss a
is a local Center on the scheduling to
enhance the sustainability of the
locally important services and you've
heard some of the mentioned backhands
for a lot there and to enable wider than
local needs to be met
and I've just looked in the in our
planning document here where it speaks
about
the local plan and Rural dwellings
across the rural areas of a size and
tenure reflecting local needs
and demands in support of local vision
and development strategies still I'm
going to move this from the chair for
the improve it
councilor Christine yeah I'll second
that
um local news housings are very
difficult are they because we get a lot
which
um
well it'd be like I say it was
stretching the truth a bit you know the
local means is it there this one I think
clearly is actually and it is an
interesting site I've looked at on
Google Earth
anything to replace the not being rude
but the tumble down bar would be good
um can I just ask one thing though that
I find a bit old on page 107 the very
last paragraph of this application
it says the applicants did not enter
into pre-act discussions which is always
a Pity because clearly that would help
but it goes on um it says
the council's decision based on a
decision which set out this assessment
on a previous planning application which
African was aware of when submitting
this and yet when I looked on page 98
lists the relevant history the only
previous application online is from
1984. now I hope we're not taking into
account 38 years ago uh stuff because
where is the other previous application
I apologize to answer that is just uh
[Music]
that's put on the end of each decision
whether it's approval review and
um according to what type of application
it is it's the difference in the text
that is overlapping at the case
um can I just um they obviously going
against the recommendation and
uncomfortable you've articulated reason
for that what we will need is um
condition
um if you'd like me to make some
suggestions for that chair based on the
officers report
um yeah so we would be looking at it was
an outline applications
and and indeed
the Environmental Protection Officer has
recommended condition to restrict powers
and construction to tie the dwell into
the business and the full contamination
condition now in regards to tying the
dwelling to be a joining business we
will also need a unilateral undertaking
to secure the dwelling of the local news
dwelling that I would suggest at that
time to the business Falls within that
as well
um because I don't believe that the
running businesses within the red line
for the application so I would recommend
the unilateral undertaking given the
applicant is in control of everything
restricting the local news dwelling but
also time time back in there
[Music]
um
yeah and just
three more
um members made one and I I would
recommend that it's delegated and have a
set of length and a condition just
requiring any access Park in the new
things being in place by association
about drainage scheme you'll noticeable
importance reference that uh
submitted that we wouldn't suggest that
prior to occupation to make the prize
commencement that we didn't have that
confirmed to be in the bowel drainage
and then finally as as mentioned by the
author a condition to require any
development to be carried out in the
course of the ecology report and that
Reserve massive stage we would get
confirmation with any biodiversity for
instance then that would be my
suggestion which I remember games
um
I'm in full supporters application
um one being obviously rural business
trying to support this about end up in
the East wedding I think the gentleman
and Luther he always 18. 18 local people
we had to do a business was absolutely
fantastic for a young chat not demeanor
at also I think they're really fantastic
at this I I wish you the best local
feature going forward but I the
condition is a better sign it to the the
business
this will have some that I'll try to
support it up again here because tiny
the business to the dwelling I don't
want to then come into you've been
stipulations for hours of work for this
gentleman because obviously foreign
it would be quite the opposite in that
if whoever's living in the dwelling and
also operates the business that means
there would be no restrictions I think
the concern would be if they were
separated and some somebody came and
operated that business when there's a
connecting dwellings but it wouldn't be
restrictions it would just mean that
whoever lives in the dwelling that there
is that connection
in the operating times
councilwise thank you chair
um I don't agree with the officers
breaking Honestly though interestingly
um the business is okay what race and
people drive through at the work but not
okay to drive from a house at the same
point
um I've got some misgivings about tying
this application to the business got the
bid through notebook of their own if the
business ceases trading what happens
then
well it should be a local means to
everyone it would still be a local music
dwelling
um I think the it would only become an
issue in whoever was living in that if
the business was operating and whoever
was living in that dwelling
um was unconnected to it so the
condition is recommended from the um
Environmental Protection of them because
there would be environment those um
amenities you can plan over the
proximity I think if the business needed
to exist
um I mean the main reason for this is an
amenity issue it's the dwelling isn't
being approved pure enough to serve that
business there's a really Connection in
that sense
if at any time that business needs to
exist
um
they'd still be the applicant would
still be able to live in the dwelling
it's more that you couldn't operate
separately with the two and if that did
come about we need to look at these are
very interesting to do their actual
undertaking
based on those circumstances and any
Humanity impacts would be considered at
that time you know what I don't want is
there to be an excuse to
take the seedings that someone could
lose at home yeah
that's not the intention it is to
protect both the business and the future
rather than in this case they're they're
one of them
good point to clarify if I can survive
again
right unless anybody else wants to
contribute
I suppose that we recommend approval
cancer Crystal statement because
thank you chair let's look better
Instagram
well you know obviously approvement
I don't know
we moved online now to our
final application before we break their
lunch break we'll choose 17 on pages
108.24
[Music]
um
I'm just like you mentioned at the top
of the page
thanks to the mining and the leather
called in the application if the
opportunity remind me to support I did
not get that long because among them as
well I did the boxer and planning
committee members which doesn't commit
the wrong way or the other day but I
didn't call and if it was managing to be
supported Mr carried about it thank you
so I am in this University
[Music]
cycle
[Music]
so this is a location plan uh so where
you um
[Music]
and these are some error images again
just uh
close but you might be able to see
clicking on that sort of
[Music]
endometrios they've sort of generally
predictable causes loans with mainly
similar nature
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and this is a new type of
placement I think it's a church in
relationship and again
[Music]
um I think it's pretty good to know
which I've noted in the romance report
s and see sort of diversity sort of
nature of uh off-roading and small
engagement sort of farms there quite
often
[Music]
um
you're not accessing these words so you
don't know but many of the abilities now
[Music]
unless you just don't access points
subscribe to the right
um
[Music]
today
and this is a new this is sort of uh
within the central part of the
application site so we sort of hang
around here
[Music]
Supply Direction
and we see another degree more questions
[Music]
recovery
[Music]
you need to review itself
[Music]
so the image on the left is an image
from sort of straight to the rear of the
top of the metal and looking forward
[Music]
I think it was quite clear to know that
it's something about anything
so I understand
foreign
[Music]
online
[Music]
right
[Music]
um
and this is a plot plan which should go
into the
development I suppose
um
and also we can see again that
relationship between several problems
and the properties would be just about
to the other side
with uh
and just leaving to show that
um again another site plan
[Music]
and I've just then zoom in to show the
site levels
and see it but
you want some problems
[Music]
values
is
[Music]
this is the drink plan which is provided
by the actual environment
it shows
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh here's a series of motivational
blinds but the applications
[Music]
allowing a more flexible
regulations designed to understand
within their Marketplace
Independence extensions in my report
localized
[Music]
their attention
um
again the the application part as a
result of this
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
feed this flow have any practices
so considered what would be added
um
[Music]
between
[Music]
and whereas the general
um and long-term impactivity that can be
moderate
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
the original banana surviving we're not
visiting some psychic Factory
[Music]
consulted them as a positive on
follow-up during the clouds they the
great accounts were found in this life
within the representation report which
specifically looks at the aspects of
these and also requisition in terms of
the incident report outside the land
ownership and also the internet
[Music]
wanted to go
uh in terms of apology the council
receiving Point reports um
[Music]
principal development is not successful
being in a sustainable locations
[Music]
is that
increases
in these effects are not significant and
not emotionally in that way the benefits
of the two ways
to recommend approval thank you
that'd be right
uh
that we've got the true contributions
for this the first one will be councilor
Haynes on behalf of Northern Parish
County
foreign
Town Council planning committee
um northern cancers of the proposed to
accuse of this application consider that
the Bolton's design of the two houses
proposed to the school site would not
fit the character and street scene in
the area and constitute over to
thousands with Consultants insufficient
amendments in space space for the
occupants
councilors also agree with local
residents that the development can
result in adverse overlooking of
neighboring properties
contrary to LP policy dno one regarding
amenity Northern councils consider that
there will be unacceptable impact on the
development on the narrow access
cul-de-sac where Vehicles often have to
be reversed out drivers of delivery
emergency and service vehicles and
Motors generally would be adversely
affected by the increased traffic
generated from the new houses
there will be a likely increase in
visitors cars from her group from the
proposed houses being parked on the road
which would cause Styler crappy problems
given the lack of passing and turning
faces and the deathspurs between
endangered by the left earned by the
actual practice bearing in mind that
there is no pavement provision
there is also the impact on the street
and construction vehicles which would
likely have to reverse out along the
Stream
the further reason given by councils for
refusal is that there will be an
unacceptable
maturities of consequent loss of
biodiversity and immunity
it should also be mentioned that
residents have challenged the accuracy
at about who's showing the plans and
with strong concerns have been expressed
about the drainage system industry and
the possibility
it is of relevance to the issues that
Northern councilors have raised that in
2012 a previous occupation on the site
for single dwelling application 1032 was
refused on the same ground that is as
being a cramped form of development out
of keeping with the surrounding area
likely to have detrimental effect on
immunities of surrounding residents
inadequate went to the access in order
to lack of report waste given this
previous position and the reasons I
reported to you Northern Town Council
considers that the likely harm of The
Proposal would outweigh any benefits and
therefore recommend some reviews this
application
thank you Council
our next speaker against the application
is illenables
foreign
[Music]
first one ground level and privacy
[Music]
levels given the height above our
property needs as per my significant
true cross-section this would be the
equivalent of at least three-story
houses for the height of 10.7 meters or
35 feet in old money looming over our
properties blocking our lighting and
totally compromising the Privacy which
we enjoy at the moment by having direct
line of sight and developed members in
our into our rear Gardens and into my
bedroom kitchen and living room and
those are the other properties in
Goodwood Park roads so committee reports
States the eaves fight of the new
building at the 3.8 meters not the
height of the veluxe windows mentioned
about which are considerably higher I
estimate from the significant drawings
to do 5.5 liters or 18 feet even in the
height above my property that's 8.5
meters or 28 foot
the ground level of the site is
considerably higher to the lower line
properties to the Eastern mind has
clearly stated in the Egyptians put
forward on storage Capital planning site
by the relevant residents
the very close proximity of plot one to
the boundary of the Buffalo Institute of
the west but also completely compromise
their privacy furthermore the top 17 to
my boundary to the south of the site to
constitute in my opinion the potential
advancing danger given that two meter
drop which is one meter with inside my
boundary
Prince and Trump's I'm also concerned as
to the removal but the trees and shrubs
so I'm very close to my family frankly
they have been getting in my opinion
this apparently instability of the
ground given the proximity to the two
meter difference in ground level where
would the success water now granted
previously the trees constructs clearly
assisted the natural drainage also
provided habitats to betterness that
I've seen that I could see and roosts
for other wildlife
following on from my previous comments
I've taken into consideration the
component brain which was completed or
gutted only
option A would require a trench to be
done parallel and within a meter of my
boundary and was subsequent two meter
drop again the danger of Lance is
evidence then traverses the entire route
of my garden again necessitating the
movement of well-established jobs which
assists in the supporting a steeply
sloping Bank from the west of my
property option b to burst three
properties again the removal of
well-established Bank supporting shrops
would be required
yeah visibility with a reference to the
comment committee uh dated
the type of readily visible from
glengarth close the group the degree of
separation there is no network screen
it's all gone and these properties would
be readily beautiful
in my opinion contributing policy gm01 I
cannot express enough depth I will wind
up Mr chairman
um thank you for your consideration for
these points down and do you have any
questions for me I'll be more than happy
to answer them thank you personal
benefit
s
very quick but it's not very long
right our next speaker against the
proposal is Harold Garner
and not recycled you three minutes as
well thank you
to address them
selors
um
there's a presentation by the Gully
family Herald together with the total
community of Glendale Police also the
Colt family in conkers and investment
neighbors and don't Blaine this is a new
Anonymous objection to this proposed
development
it's high density development of two
four bedroom houses that's out of
keeping and inappropriate Within These
Bungalow areas of both glencas close and
Goodwood Park
the 1960 The Glen architos Bungalow
development made provision for a small
driveway as access to a one-bedroom Glen
Cottage
we understand this access is not the
property of Glen and cottage and it
measures only 2.4 meters wide and 25
meters long
too narrow for most Builders lorries or
equipment let alone an ambulance or
delivery vehicle
the proposed change of use of the area
from one bedroom to a total of eight
bedrooms producing unacceptable problems
the access Drive becomes a service road
which runs within two beaches pedal
South Windham
there will be increased traffic noise
pollution
there appears to be no parking for
Britain for their the visitors Vehicles
these proposed houses will have direct
view into neighborhoods to the South
Google Park to the West coffins also
North heaven
every existing Green Life Of All Trades
has been destroyed there will be no room
for replanting proposed treatment
between the houses and the boundaries
and I I see that you've been showing up
because ground plan which incorrectly
includes the apron area of edulgaria
an area of some 80 square meters parking
for four cars within headless boundary
this plan indicates a better site access
than actually exists
site material and Equipment will have to
be dropped off the lingard close is
already overburdened
with parking and delivery
at the lower end of Glen Golf boasts any
drop-off will prevent access to at least
four properties
the main surge pipeline or darn laying
communities is a six-inch tutorial clean
bike
in
2007-10 three properties at the bottom
of glengarth plus experience sewage
backup and flooding some of the system
was subsequently lined and we were
advised that further learning would be
unwise
finally no part of pebble's ground is
available for development contrary to
the proposed plan
the plan boundary shown
could we request that should an
appropriate sized plan be presented
for a single residence
and that that it would be for
residential occupation only no Airbnb
commercial or holiday let's
thank you
thank you
[Music]
our next speaker is Keith speaking on
behalf of the advocate and support
and once you settled solution
three minutes to present for the
community good afternoon please
I apologize in advance I learned about
this me being here today last night
according to my own special protect the
company
[Music]
all I can tell you is what I believe is
a very quick notes I've had two hours to
do it
I believe we satisfied a lot of the uh
playing issues not all of them
regards to the access which I've just
heard people from my accent
but we have just had in there a free
time cheap
with a tie axle trailer on the back
driving out of the property of aquarium
without giving automatic damage or
against the highways
Amazon Fire
d by my colleague in his father's
property
we employ 16 people
part of the planning was to keep those
people employed in the loaded sentences
we will also look at when they say
Deliverance of trucks we appreciate that
having worked on what I call tightness
sites in the past
we do not cause problems for our
neighbors we don't want all the problem
with our neighbors to see that access to
the book with uh with any Department say
is considered and we look not causing
any doctors
it's not too much else than I've already
got an invincible
it's the properties we're developing is
I mean we think keeping with which
nobody exists in an area
so let's be short and sweet I'll have to
ask the two lesson two hour drive coming
up and you've got any questions for me
I'll try and answer them
[Music]
that's right it is thank you thank you
very much
right that's the end of the speakers
councilman McGovern yeah thanks Mr
chairman
I'm going straight to the drug liver I
mean I'll get a vote we refuse this
application on Sport and Northern Town
Council decision on the planet there
I've seen do you ever won the immunity
and that does to me it's a major impact
the immunity of the residents of the
area and it is well over development in
my my opinion and the two dwellings I
would certainly put in this lands are
demonstrable right there they're just
ginormous
and it's not in keeping them in the area
so that's my main thing and obviously
the biodiversity area which I agree you
know being absolutely obliterated anyway
so I I'm definitely refusing I'd like to
produce application on those grounds
thank you so much Council Christie our
second there
um when I read through this I was
slightly surprised in Northern Town
councilman had four consultations which
has to be a record
um on all of them they say exactly the
same thing mind you uh obviously access
has got some Gotham pointed out is
horrific if you have walked up there
delivering leave for this and it is
quite horrific but the thing that did
surprise me and I realized this is has
finally balanced application from our
officer on page 117
yeah
the second paragraph which I don't think
I've read before second paragraph if
you're talking about the design
notwithstanding this the proponent
design is considered to be poor and then
if you go to the third and bottom of
that uh paragraph This is a generally
poor design
um and on that ground alone I think I'll
turn it down because I've never seen
that before in an application without
the officer had actually said well this
is pretty poor and I don't think we as a
committee can actually say oh I support
his eye but we're still past it it
doesn't send out the right message to
the public so I will second Chaos on the
door dm4
designing principles
yeah
Council Pennington thank you chair
um question really
um page 109 the rest of History
um a bit of a variation in the history
period because some of the dates on the
last well they should have been put
earlier it seems to me
um the second Accenture Haynes mentioned
application I think I heard it correctly
is uh 1032 2012 which I understood was
for two properties and Olympic views and
it's not listed there and that's the
what was mpw what I should know that I
know what does npw stand for
um
thank you sir okay
history
and thank you councilman I believe in
touch the application I thought several
applications introduce the application
including in 2002.
thank you
[Music]
um
okay thank you thank you chair
um you can see from the dates of the
application was 23 and roll this moment
we're considered
and it has been a Minefield to try to
get anything
resolved on the site and for me and it
was one of the reason that it comes in
the drainage
if you look at the
that's like you know the book slide with
the trains on but I printed off last
night that was that time
the drainage plan
water
[Music]
and the bottom of all existing small
Bungalow is in the corner of the same
and it's crisscrossed with bowel sewers
now all that says water again management
is the backlit they occurred
moves and it happens if they're
expensive the ability to move them to on
that side if you look at the plan of the
two that ain't all the same boats
there's no way that and the other thing
that I would strongly get to is
Southwest Waterstone well as far as the
circuit walk away we can't have a circle
around the site
and they can take me through to Google
Park Road to service through people's
back Gardens and through third-party
land which census will have statically
parasite but I don't think you can just
women of course he'll be positioned like
that just for one through developing
that God maybe if this is a voluntary
mistake the only way you could connect
with a circus walking streams and stuff
like that you could but I I think it's
absolutely important that's quoted in
the years being a way that they might
lose all the surface water so
and it is very
apparently you know
well you read out the designated
appalling councilor Rock
yeah I've also got a note page 17 the
second paragraph
um couldn't seem to be a broad design
but using contemplary choice and
materials but as we all know design and
use materials and subjective matters and
people absolutely different in their
opinions
um one other small boy in the obviously
important for the September meeting
mention was made that should the
application be approved
um there should be um conditional or
informative but removing permitted
development rights but I could not find
any mention of that in our October
report
um if I could on that Council right yes
[Music]
[Music]
yep
right thank you well we've had um [ __ ]
long quality it's been recommended very
community
[Music]
I've maybe not to be a BMI one who's
been one of the policies
pml4 which has been going on and with
the F12 achieving well-designed places
um
and also not
I should put in this I'm not having I
don't know with the sewage situation on
site despite the fact was more different
but I don't think it could easily have
been considered it properly it's never
been on the side of the hospital but the
problem you heard the problems mentioned
by a woman speaking there has been
politicians of food in the past downwind
out there it's a very long time
right well it's much uh
[Music]
[Music]
as well
um so it's been moved to refuse by
councilman God sent me by Council please
can you just please be we used very few
results foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yeah I'm I'm I'm happy that that's
that's the appropriate policy and that
they're in specifically covered the
concerns that big Ray the things I
picked up
poor design quality being out tripping
on the surrounding contacts
um impact on men and team and
going back to design with open
development so
um I think the chair is happy then that
should be all for next week as well
um officers can draft a reason for them
circulated but it would be according to
those policies
I would say I have a lot of symptoms
thanks John right sound if you take the
book please
that's extreme pressure on highways
without cash or anything it's probably
with it
okay thank you
thank you can we just get it clear with
Jim we were voting for if we're against
them yes right
here yeah
thank you so we're voting for review so
that's about 104.
cancer Brown Chancellor Christie or
cancer leather or Council a lot for
councilor mcgough four councilor
Pennington or pencil Wiseman oh
unanimous to refuse thank you
well it's important
[Music]
we'll we'll take our breaks for lunch
now
oh no
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in terms of verbal updates there have
been additional representations
principle looking to report was
published and the original publication
of the report back in September
um some of these were submitting in
response to that complication and the
report has been updated to reflect those
there there isn't anything above and
beyond what is in your community records
and give this highlight as well the case
up with their would take it back more on
this application so I am presenting in
her plate
um I am I am very familiar with the site
and have been involved throughout the
process if there is a specific question
I do have access to the document so I
just want to raise that now that it
hasn't been my answer thank you
um had been called in by Council Holcomb
the reason set out in your agenda report
the only other verbal update to report
is out of the application this morning
the outline application that went to the
park the highway Authority have made a
similar request for this application
that the planning obligations sort of
buses and sustainable transport
could
they would like them to be sent like
have that flexible option spending
towards a Hayward Road roundabout so
there's a name which is
just moving on to the presentation this
is the site location plan that goes with
the application it is and the quite
extensive site the total area is
approximately 18.8 hectare there is an
area of blue highlighted one in Japan
that's into identify land also within
the ownership of the applicant and you
will have seen in the agenda that
references alongside biodiversity
netgage scheme
and reference to a biodiversity field
that field is within the blue line that
you can see before we moved
again just showing a slightly different
plan that shows the concept I can build
form of wet and home so looking at this
you can see the site is shading in green
and outlined in red
it's it to the to the south of the built
form of Westwood Hill that I'm sure
you'll appreciate the topography as such
that Western fair is that better to the
north of the lower a lower level
um but part number six travels through
the side you can see the purple rooting
of the path going
um along the lower lower half of the of
the site cornbread road is the
um the road immediately to the north of
the application site and fusel Road into
the West
for showing an aerial photo now and you
can you can see from this that it is the
whole site is agricultural land there
are defined field boundaries in The
Wider site there aren't any existing
buildings or structures within the
application side
this is the an extract from the north
Devon towards local plan policies map 8A
which covers Northern and West Widow the
site is allocated for development under
obviously nor zero two and this is the
the area
so it is this allocation here which
covers
um totality an area greater than the
application science
um however this application does the
majority of that allocation in terms of
Site Area
the majority of the application is
within the development boundary So
within that more zero two allocation
there is um according to a field to the
south of the development boundary
um which where it's supposed to bring
forward biodiversity enhancements and
elements of the public open state so no
significant built form you will see from
this extract that that does encroach
into land that is subject to nor 10
which is the green wedge the purpose of
that policy or that protection is to
prevent coalescence between the built
form of resettlement and the support and
text that policy indicates that that
land within green when green wedge
should be kept only for them
this plan identified
um Heritage Assets in proximity to the
site so maybe it's not slightly favored
the ballistic buildings
um closest proximity are shown so there
is
um the building annotation is number two
for that to be to the west of the
application site and then there are a
couple listed buildings further down to
the South
this plan shows the relationship of the
applications like the north Devon era of
outstanding natural beauty which is
which is shaded in dark green and
showing against them the location of the
application site
then have the blood mapping the
environment agency blood mapping which
which confirms that the vast majority of
the science of London one there is a
small existing water course that runs
South along the Southwest boundary but
for the most part it is in flood zone
one
this slide to show the comparison
um between the development boundary the
allocation and the application of
science so as I described earlier this
application does get extend beyond
reallocation and development boundary
and this this plan just shows it within
which that is the case
as I said earlier the application site
will form a component of more tooth it's
not the whole allocation and we have had
two previous planning permissions and we
have a current application and other
parts or of the allocation
um so the area shaded in blue that's the
development that has been built out 432
dwellings that was an application
referenced 2013 the yellow area is a
site that benefits from outline and
Reserve matters for 145
and that's under construction and then
the purple area down at the that east
corner is the current application for
117 dwellings so though these three
other applications in addition to the
application performing today
that amounts to the the total area of
normal energy
we'll just run through a series of
photos now
um members
obviously benefited from the size of a
number of videos during the site with it
um which is as a reminder so this is a
great top northwest corner of the side
um Canberra Road things beyond that
hedge that that property you can see
Foams on to
um it starts with very Northern top
you'll hope you see from these back is
how steep Society is the Topography is
quite significant in the slope when we
moved out of town
as you can appreciate here so this is
the top of the corner looking down on
the side
you see that the bottom of that of that
field looking back up the appeal road on
the left properties Benton Cobra Road up
at the top
again this is looking back further down
to the south from the middle of the
sides looking down
that makes
um with the names in it sort of the
other side of the Hedge there so those
were being one of the potential Parts
essentially application
again this is just another another photo
looking back up you can see the
development that's under construction
and at the moment
to the lower portion of the site you can
see the level it doesn't never have the
site gets to that no one plant
and again he's right down to the
southern southern part of the side which
is agricultural grazing land at the
moment
the public right-of-way runs directly
along the left hand side of this section
a bit of the side effects standing below
that's the way the the currently under
construction the application side of the
field
within the stone chain
and this is which is right down at the
bottom corner of the site
this cornbread Road this would be the
junction of pewter Road the new Junction
out of the development would come out
onto cornbread roughly at this point but
slightly further along
and this is looking in the other
direction just showing the current
condition of Calder Road
this is the junction of cumber road with
Buckley Road
um there are Works proposed to to
improve this
Junction continues and through widening
and pedestrian enhancement and then
we've all been a plan to show that later
okay that's just sharing and smoking
further back view of between conjunction
with Buckley Road
and now some sort of distant views so
this is from cornbread
the red to the extent of the flight
field line there so if it's um the
further west along the road
with the views within the thighs
um looking out pretty much over the
whole site you can just see feudal Road
sort of heading down in the bottom shot
on the right
this is a Viewpoint from Hughesville
Road itself
so you can see that the topography bed
that that upper part of the site is they
can be higher and then the land of
changed quite a significantly level the
North and South
different chemists lay by students back
across towards the site you can see the
clouds build their annotating site
through one and then Progressive at that
lower level nests in the landscape
you can have it in footpath and within
the arnb again being the slightly to
screen by photography but the highest
part of the site is is really visible
from that point
even with that down and again we can see
the various Fields annotates with their
by extend crowns but not about the
properties to get on the top there on
Cornwall Road
this is from 15 within the AMD
so the topography does scream apart from
content from this moments
to be from
campaign Carriage um
field which
um which is suitable for the most
important
the Minor Road abachem so this is
looking to come out of that machine back
across
and it's got the Greenville estate
quite the distance across to where the
flight lives
um but nicely in the context of other
allocations that are on on that sort of
side of the hill this could be from
Valley Road Raleigh Road
[Music]
and deeper of Northern based accounting
powers of the site would be paid for
that having the ground down here
they would the application has been
outlined it's only access poor
determination at this stage however we
have had provided an indicative site
plan so they could not call a
determination to show how the level of
development proposed could be
accommodated within the night you will
see that there is the point a bit the
connection onto Road and then to the
points of connection one into the
development that's under construction at
the moment and then a further point of
view of the connection coming through to
the application that's currently on the
determination
there would be a series of sort of green
Open Spaces Green Space going through
um the site itself the field that sits
outside of the
um of the development boundary you can
see here that that has been brought into
the application site but it's not
proposed to build any dwellings on that
so you can see there would be 34 to
drainage informal kick around area or
more formal Sports pitch and from a lot
of them at the moment you can just do
the oncology build that's just beyond
and this is showing the very top section
of the sign up to the point will be if
they're accessed onto cornbread Road
and again that's more detailed technical
Highway drawing and that's in for the
core member small approval consideration
today
this shows the point of um cornbread
Road meeting Buckley Road so where do
um enhancement works off-site and cars
from the highway where it should take
place this also shows football 26 where
it's also for about to do some
resurfacing so I just scan it is this
book path that heads down towards
Seafield House
um took on the site it's it's the one
that heads up towards the west and
northern part and it was
this diagram shows the proposed
Improvement to their cornbread Buckley
Road Crossing and it would involved
incorporating some Crossing Point
improving pedestrian
um
Provisions there who enhance put ways
and an element of Road widening to
accommodate that
this is part 26 and I just mentioned for
this class has been resurfaced and
improved to provide that improved
projection runs out of Wexford home
um more detailed drawing of the water
judges you can see that the normal wood
connects except you can be connected
into some feature and then dischargeable
Watercourse
this is Southwest water mapping showing
the um
bowel drainage connection points
the current habitat map so it's a mix of
non-zero crops the sort of orange
shading and modified grassland
and the tree protection plan that's been
provided albeit indicatively to show how
trees would be protected on the site
then just moving on to the main planning
considerations
the principal of development the site is
allocated for development
um within the north Government College
local plans there is an element of the
application that is outside of the
development boundary
new built development is proposed aside
from Baltimore training rooms into the
football pitching allotments and given
the oriented position more than can't
demonstrated by the alongside Housing
Development outside of the developmental
can be considered at this time it's also
considered that there isn't the conflict
with more 10 which is the green wage
policy given the nature of any works and
development outside of the development
boundaries would have been the open
space and a lot of members have been
ecological benefits landscape character
and digital impact the application is
supported by
um elastic Vision impact assessment
which does identify harm arriving out of
the development and it does also it's
just investigation measures to direct to
reserve massive application the offices
report does acknowledge there is harm to
the landscape that that needs to be seen
in the context of The Wider allocation
and the fact that it is assigned to
developing the housing Heritage and
Archeology there's no objections raised
from Devon archeology all the
conservation there are however
conditions recommended
residential Melody
again subject to condition restricting
hours of construction
there being a construction management
plan
Etc with no objections at this stage
more detailed methods of things
appearing and privacy would be
considered at the beach on stage
Highway that is the local Highway
Authority subject to suggested
conditions and section 106 obligations
being secured rating no objection
again collaborate some drainage the
flood Authority and Stafford Center are
both supportive subject condition in
terms of ecology the team would would
deliver 10 by the rest of net gain not
the combination of on and off-site
provision and would be able to logical
management plan to secure and manage
that in the long term
section 106 obligations the the
application is policy compliant it does
speak to about 30 affordable housing and
all of the other obligations that have
been requested are set out on your
agenda report so moving on to the
planning balance and the conclusion the
we are
it is it is the committee to apply the
children balance and we don't have a
final answer site at the moment which
which means assessing whether the harm
any identified harm outweighs the
benefits the opposite report clearly
sets out the benefits associated with
the proposal BTUs for the most part
allocated for for the development that
his own it is considered to be a
sustainable location
um there are benefits both in terms of
super economics through the construction
stage and then residents supporting
existing services and so that we've
constructed social benefits through the
delivery of affordable housing money
towards the primary saw and significant
levels of public open space and whilst
all of these are to serve the needs of
the development due to their scale there
would be a wider benefit beyond the
Greater Community
harm that have been identified as
mentioned is allowance get home to the
landscape albeit this must be seen in
the context of it being an allocated
site
um however on balance you offices
recommendation is one of approval
subjects to the conclusions with the and
securing reception agreement for the
very compelling obligations
okay thank you very much
introduction and
presentation of the application our
first speaker is on behalf of the parish
council Jennifer
things
together again
other cancers
one understanding of this application is
on a designated site there are matters
to with the proposed development about
which Northern councilors have expressed
great concern in expressing this concern
they reflect the issues raised by the
large number of objectives and
specifically by the arnb and by wall
councils
regarding the impacts on the countryside
than the aonb and other matters it is
northern's view that the provisions of
policy noor2 have not been
satisfactorily implementing
the policy requirement of the density of
the development is diminished in the
northern sites of the southern and
western parts it's not being satisfied
this is mainly due to the excessive
amount of Parsons proposed to the site
following the aoms observation we have
stated that our objections that the 400
houses for 390 will constitute 54 of the
overall nort sites on a relatively small
section of it this housing density is
fall too high leading to inadequate open
space Landscaping Recreation areas and
breathing infrastructure a Cold Spring
adverse visual impacts on the
countryside will be compounded by the
sharp edges of the developments the
inadequate sent with the agreement the
proposed smaller houses at the top of
the site and the potential light
pollution from the houses all these
factors mean that the testing policy nr2
are providing an appropriate
relationship with the countryside will
not be met
Northern cancers are also greatly
concerned about the access arrangements
to the estate with only one entrance in
Cornwall road if it's concerned too
about the serious impact on traffic
pedestrians and cyclists on that road
and the Buckner Road production
resulting from the homes of traffic
movements generated by residents of the
proposed houses
in this respect council is considered
the nr2 and indeed local planning
policies DMO born bmo5 have not been
satisfied
or reflected in the planning conditions
in terms of providing an integrated
public transport pedestrian cycle
Network which would minimize car use and
provide alternative safe travel to the
shops and services of northern and
western only
house is considered to that inadequate
connections being provided for
transports in the neighboring
development
regarding infrastructure provision it
seems a concrete to nr2 no retail or
Community provision will be available on
the site thus leading to increased car
use and putting huge pressure on local
medical care schools and other services
the main objections to this development
and to other developments which have
come before you constantly Express the
alarm local restaurants feel about
inadequate provision of infrastructure
the case of a large increase in
population in the area
in summary this application does not
fully meet the conditions of nr2 and
fails to meet the applicants claim that
the development will be sustainable
without Hospitality recommend you reduce
the applications and seek revised
proposals which will lead the
requirements to be referred to thank you
thank you Council names
uh
our next contribution is from John and
Pat Friedman a general statement and
stays the Earth will presenters
[Music]
thank you
all right so I just wondered would be
possible to read out with a submission
to the council at the planning meeting
this Friday
there is a massive information on the
TVC website similar to other
applications for large sites to forgive
us if we get things wrong as it is
impossible to read all that is said we
appreciate that the majority of the site
is within no zero two and thus dedicated
as a site for housing
I believe that a field outside the nor
zero two Zone has also been included in
the application and this field will
provide Green Space however nothing can
take away from the fact the site will be
densely packed more dense than any of
the other sites in nor zero two
this breaks the requirements stipulated
in the local plan that density should
diminish to the Western Southern
boundaries
I believe this requirement was put in to
protect the amb which borders the site
the arnb have objected what the response
from the developers is not an operation
they're either the layout or the density
but just extra extra green blobs on
their plan these green blobs represent
Hedges and trees
many will form boundaries of Gardens and
properties and will be dependent on
westerns as to whether they are
maintained
the biggest area covered with boiling
blobs is the top of the site which would
be fine if that area was not battered by
Fierce Southwest salty winds something
great and making Landscaping extremely
difficult
King's land has limited development on
the grover Hill that this site seeks to
place the most expensive and biggest
houses there thus making the site
extremely visible from a distance
however TDC finds itself in an
unemployable position a condition of 30
affordable housing has been placed in
this development
how will Thomas make sure that this
comes to fruition even if the site
changing pounds
ernestology can explain this so often
comparability profitability making the
day mean to developer can ease remove
the condition
[Music]
we see no reason why the site should
seek to provide so many houses other
than profit it will play some extra
strain on all the infrastructure that
has has to go into to support it it is
sad at this very time the planning
committee comes the planning comes to
committee the shop in Deer Park is no
longer
even more people having to use the car
to get that extra pint of milk unless of
course you are super fit and can both
make it up the hill whilst going
shopping pushing and bugging
the roads around the site are
substandard but please stand well of
course Bay View but there is very little
that can be done about them by lowering
density and there were traffic flow
I read that in the past the developers
have said that you were able to go
you have to be able to build enough
houses toward developing a site but
Kingsland Deer Park and the proposed
children home site have all reduced the
density permitted yet I'm sure they'll
still make a profit to stop playing
games the fight is there could be better
but let's make it clear it is the best
it can be both the future residents
neighbors holiday makers enjoying the
coastal bar
this need never going to appeal a little
bit of tinkering and perhaps a little
less profit will make it conform with
the requirements ignore zero two
we have concerns about the statement in
the design and access statement which
talks about a positive response
was there what was the positive
responsible for the TDP planning
department was GDP defending the
requirements of the local plan in
respect of nor zero two
we appreciate Karen has to answer to
remaining Masters but even the local
plan starts with something or nothing an
increased in density of this scale an
alteration of the layout requirements on
such a sensitive sideways into many
questions and undermines the serious
serious discussions that took place and
the area was included in the local plan
foreign
Becky Chalmers
did committee speaker and any other
interested parties I am very concerned
about this development for several
reasons
retail and Community facilities the
north Devon and college local plan state
in providing some new Housing
Development it is necessary to ensure
that there is a great grip range of
distribution of community facilities and
services to meet residents needs the
most appropriate location for the
provision of community facilities is
within or adjacent to adaptable where
they are readily accessible by the
populations they serve and the impact on
the countryside is minimized
this part of North West Westwood High
Who currently has no real infrastructure
in place and thus nor zero two starting
with the deer Parkside was to provide a
local Center including the 30s to
accommodate community and Retail uses
this seems like a welcome addition to
the area however the building allocated
for the center has now been boarded up
and turned into two ground floor
Apartments which are currently being
offered for sale by Wayne Holmes can the
commit why this is the case
nor zero one is supposedly going to
divide the area with an extra pair
facility
420 page primary school and neighborhood
community center can the committee
please explain how we can be sure that
these will actually transpire after the
promise of a retail unit was not honored
a lot I'll cover a lot of current or
residents so a lot current of residents
Tunes to move to this part of Westwood
home and Paul gave some conveniences
because it was more tranquil you can see
why people are concerned when you're
proposing to create a new Village Hall a
new Village of 1300 homes in an area
that can barely sustainably support
those already living here particularly
when your plan state and significant
growth is projected in all those or
pensionable age
older people tend to be more dependent
on services and local amenities
the nearest shop and Community hubs are
in Westwood home not walkable for many
Elder people young families or disabled
people due to seek gradient
local schools and lot of surgeries are
Emma subscribed
the development that has been built so
far does not meet residents needs nor
facilities within or adjacent to
Middleburg
so what will the committee do to tackle
this and is it prudent to proceed until
this has been addressed
transport the local plan states that
held in development should be accessed
without generating unacceptable levels
of traffic on the local Road Network and
or reducing highway safety
the current bus service is pittable only
three times a day two days a week and
takes 35 minutes to get to Biddeford
in order that the Building Development
has a minimal impact on the country's
side as stated in a plan would you think
car usage is key
I'm sure that there will be those that
say that the service provided is Barely
Used but from my experience no one wants
to use an infrequent unreliable service
that doesn't get you to where you want
to be in a reasonable time frame
in addition there is no service on
buckover road or Bayview road where most
of the building is concentrated
can the committee please comment on how
this is going to be addressed
thirteen hundred our houses could
potentially generate 2 000 cars in this
area
the road Network simply cannot cope with
this kind of traffic despite plans to
avoid will improved roads and Junctions
without reducing highway safety there
are just too many pinch points and a
lack of Pavements around Buckley roads
Hughes Hill Road and Sandwell Hill
please can the committee convincingly
explain how they are going to limit
congestion and maintain safety
[Music]
right our next speaker then in support
of the applications Craig Graham Easton
yeah
thank you not too many minutes thanks to
present the committee don't get off your
chair
my name is Graham Easton and I'm the
construction director of engineering
application
[Music]
we were a bit of a base company our
president duterte from Building
Development of the tabworthy road in
Western home so I think somebody will be
able to
we're a local Builders and we pride
ourselves in using a very large number
of things
[Music]
on our resistance sign lives in a very
large majority of the houses told local
people old and young
[Music]
today
science and allocated site in the show
within the local plan of residents
whoever we're very close there the team
of the planning department and all the
concert teams are considerable time to
demonstrate that we think the excitement
scheme inside
actual housing numbers
will be agreed through the design
process and an observe method
application
[Music]
policy compliant application and will
deliver the 30 Target this site in
regard to much of the social rent and
Union including houses in the area
this means that well over 100 dwellings
can be provided as affordable housing to
a Housing Association for local needs
provision and secured to the section 106
agreement
furthermore the development itself
brought for a good mix of open marketing
which include one and two Federal flats
and various sites housing abundance and
I'm pleased before and we're already at
a strong local impact
the application brings together the
quality requirements the laid out of
them to including the high resolution
works and future links
it also incorporates cycleways and
public immunity and referred to in fact
the document including the provision of
a new local bus service
and we'll be providing new and
refurbished support and pedestal link to
the West Capone from the scores of
conductive Junction
other aspects of The Proposal are the
public government's faces and Parks both
that will be provided and the children
secured payment
as shown on the plan there is automatic
much sort of development which will be
available to use in the local community
we are pleased to be able to offer the
full section 106 contributions for the
NHS
which will also include the new critical
care company
remove first
and right
[Music]
also full contributions towards
education
this site is deliverable and will be a
huge benefit of watching both Northern
and surrounding
and I would hope that you agree that it
meet the desperation of the local plan
Our intention should we get a good
outcome straight to the reserve methods
and we are looking to start going before
thank you
I thank you for your time and I hope
that you can support this buddy
thank you can give me a stream
and finally on behalf of the world
member for electrical board is a
statement from councilor Claire Hobson
who couldn't be over there
with regret that I am unable to attend
the meeting of the plans committee
however however to expand the reasons
for my calling I would request the
member to consider the following
employees
dm04 design principles identity of the
team is accepted 400 properties
representative for four percent of the
taking 740 annotated for these Buckley
Road slash cornbread co-aligned sites
identified within the local plan if
granted this would deliver an additional
62 dwellings total 100 and 802 in
Warfare proceed to be promoted
environmentally sensitive of all the
previous site approvals
the aom objects the application with
regards to the impact it will have on
the landscape the layout will result in
which line development which will not
only destroy the Green Vista that will
create light pollution emanating from
these properties
the application fails to comply with
more zero to 2 a b e by not providing
integrated pedestrian cycle public
transport were made with sites the fee
does not provide the graduated
development layout which would lessen
the impact on the undeveloped Coast
it does not provide dual access to both
Cobra and Buckley roads which would if
in place reduce traffic movements via a
single access point
consideration should be given to the
already oversubscribed practices
excess 625 including consent already
the officers report regarding
contributions to the NHS state that
there will be a further 896 individuals
requiring registration for Health Care
however the community products officer
estimates the support provision that
there will be 800 to 1400 conservative
concerning variation in new cool data
Dentistry is a significant components
issue in many areas and they require
that the treatment for No Doubt exceed
availability
Community must be sustainable and
without whether they available access to
all forms of healthcare this monthly and
significant risks to be considered at
the planning stage
dividing out crime the location of the
football coaches are the southernmost
part of the development has been
commented on by the police and I would
wish that we could reiterate their
concerns regarding adopting backing onto
these recreational areas
ASB regrettably takes place in unwanted
areas and reducing the emerging by the
same Research into the young people to
access this design issue needs to be
reconsidered
nor zero two Auto states that there
should be a local Center to accommodate
Community activity and potentially a
retail outlet
s that a retail space was allocated in
the deer parking stage and they failed
to attract any commercial game
throughout however but we already
approved sides this should be air
conditioning within this application
within the response from the highways on
page 10 proposals that should be
included Expedition were then even said
given appear to have been overlooked and
excluded these four part of the
concession and consultation with the
District board members and were
considered to be essential in a local
health and safety issues for those youth
movement on certified support horseback
or an emergency vehicle they are as
follows one that's a tra we've sought to
make positive our one possible hail one
way that the develop and continue to put
past downfall to ensure a continuous
pedestrian route to Westwood hay Village
three that the 20 mile per hour rates
loan should be applied for and call that
a safety order of buckling Cross Sound
well on positive Hills be undertaken it
must be noted that a positive footpath
rules planning position 21 of the Deer
Park development which failed to be
delivered
to conclude I understand that this site
was identified for a development within
the north Devon and storage local plan
but significant constraints obligations
and conditions when described within
dn04
dm05 dm0 victim dm09 none of these
policies have been met involved
mitigations have offered within the
recommendation to approve the
application presented to this committee
by your officer in its current form are
in my opinion not substantive I would
therefore request the purpose of Jesus
current application but it's even modify
proposal which addresses the issues of
poverty non-compliance
foreign
[Music]
worked out into the boardroom
yeah
[Music]
right thank you
because that won't apply to the world
member will it yeah
okay right uh that's the end of the
contributions
and there are
if you've raised about Landscaping
Council Hill yeah thank you so I'd like
to invite Matthew Collins up the space
and a few questions about the
infrastructure in the highways so I've
been asked one of the most critical
things for this development at a moment
and I hope you might be able to
Enlighten us in their future projects
[Music]
potentially coming forward
but you're right on a spot Matthew
um it might be easily go back to
policy
and
I'm just going to go through a brief
update the various improvements that
have been made by or being made by other
sites and on site as part of the amount
of patients in this area you're
perfectly aware that the property
Junction on the 839 have been built and
I'm going to track the lines in advance
of
the development commits found here
moving up the road which
[Music]
um
the Johnson Farmington from there up to
the developments it will be widened out
at least six six and a half meters with
an additional
type of way on one side that will
continue up through with that on the
hillside
that will then join subjects and plan
information on the the application under
consideration the Footwear that will
continue through that that site onto
this site that you're considering all
the way up through the site to former
Road that's the cycle end
that other site was mentioned under
consideration is also proposing Footwear
and widely
the other narrow section
uh really signed entrance to Westerville
um
this development proposes
why why do we support practical perhaps
for a short section
across that need to provide that by the
footpath but across adjacent to the wall
that's a very narrow but
as well as three Rock Crossings to allow
pedestrians people on the relative
services and the brands etcs across and
using the different groups
[Music]
that various
um
sites in the area have provided or will
be providing bus schedules as well as I
understand the sites and my my requests
to those insectomizers to read the map
there this morning
um
so whether that's included in the
decision
uh the Deer Park site
um built by Wayne house did provide it
but we found positive appeal to a part
of previous apartment control
and this reactive and has provided works
um
[Music]
and that will be another process if it's
uh
thank you very much but I just want to
make the eye like this if members public
obviously so you can actually hear it
because I don't agree with casio's views
on this one they are obviously compliant
developers at this time and it's pretty
the potential cycle route going through
today no development and the outlying
areas the nor too there
um it coincides together it's a future
project that's going to be taking place
and
the overall of it aspect of it it
complements it because they are trying
to provide the off-site contributions as
in cycle away the foot baths the
improvements to the narrow Junctions
that we've got around the area now it's
actually nice to see a developers
actually put money into that you've got
to put manager anyway but they're not
there's no equivalent but money into it
and again on such like I did earlier on
but the big development the 30
affordable
housing there and again if we put the
central condition on there we're most
about the five-year term Etc we don't
lose the 30 affordable and again
um I think touched on hundreds weddings
going through
um social housing um
we're crying out for it you know we need
it and as an authority we haven't got
the money to go and borrow to build
around that cash sizes again we lost
that we we took that away from ourselves
years ago unfortunately so now to me
going uh looking forward to the future
now is the only way where we can
actually tackle this house in crisis and
we've got hundreds of earnings coming in
socializing needs that is I'm okay
initially we're crying out for it again
we need it this to me this application
it takes the boxes for me maybe not you
don't like your own backyard but
unfortunately we're going to please
people we're not going to please people
in our class committee so I'm going to
pose that we
Grant this application and social
condition of the deposit the 30 percent
going forward and when you look back
you're only offside contribution 106 is
they're not Provident at all all these
106 contributions are being met
and it's substantial amount of money
it's going through I'd like seeing the
other previous developments putting as
much as this but we're not talking about
them sir because we're honest with
aren't we so but I like I like the
layout you say it's really condensed on
there and it's the the light pollution
so I should like producing but I think
we there's a thing the first time I've
seen a he went to Northern Burris County
Park he looked back over the hill where
you couldn't you couldn't see it at all
he goes you you the development is
whatever Briar to him
so you can't see it so I don't really
know why we kind of showed that in there
or is that just because the anab wants
to show it so some detrimentary
development
they just need to prove that you
couldn't see it I just want to highlight
it back you could not see it from
northern burrito okay thank you thank
you
yeah I was taking accounts in the boss
um proposal it was accepted
um on phase 133 on my ways once again I
I've
read words I haven't seen before I won't
respond to people there's infrastructure
improvements have been made or will be
made in coming years from other nearby
developments I've never seen that exact
word in highways reports
um and as much as all the objections put
forward today
they will be relevant at a detailed
pattern application because today we're
just really discussing the access so I
agree with what happens when God said so
I was second his recommendation
thank you Council
Council Christie yeah um well I listen
to council holson's written uh State and
I thought was quite interesting the idea
that all right she accepts this will be
going to happen they need to go back and
slightly re-jig it I suspect that is
what we need to do here
um a couple of points though that I
found the response from the almb really
quite powerful I've never seen it quite
that strong
um saying that um you know this is
completely unacceptable as it exists at
the moment uh the second Point
um the northern surgery this has already
come up on another application of this
but northern surgery is already 25
oversubscribed and not being
disrespectful to the applicants I don't
think the 200 000 pounds they're off but
he's going to solve that in any way uh
it's you know it's me a drop in the
ocean to be honest
um so I'm not certain that's going to go
down too well
um a third point is have we had any
deals with an industry defense I say
that because I just measured it on
Google Earth
um the corner of this site where there
will be houses is 400 meters away from
low mass helicopters now I've already
had quite a few
uh complaints about learn those
helicopters they had planning permission
for one helicopter to go to London now
as you're probably aware a lot of
military
helicopters flying there to refuel
already I think councilor Hamilton's had
them as well without objections from
people living quite close to this
um not as close as this state is going
to be what happens if people come in
they have a statutory right to complain
and suddenly the ministry of defense
gets involved I think we should go and
ask them because this is quite a serious
point because that refueling stock is
now very busy and they're coming at like
three o'clock in the morning sometimes
uh the fourth point I just made the last
one and I had to make it again is I
turned to Southwest Walker by age 153
um it says uh
we've got no problems uh Southwest water
is able to provide Power sewerage
services from the existing Public Power
on site
I still remember councilor Whitaker who
was the Council of this area uh going on
about the surcharging of drain covers
with sewage pouring out in Northern
already
and again I go back to that query I read
earlier about what is the carrying
capacity of cornbread
can they actually take all the sewage
from this new development we've just
accepted one to 750 houses in benefits
it's another 400 houses
and I just
I I do wonder where we are going to get
to if it starts surcharging in large
quantities more than at the moment and
people turn around and say my toriage
around it they didn't bother trying to
get yourself vertical to do that so
again I'm afraid I can't support this
basically on the sewage if nothing else
I think uh geometry
about
Northern surgery this saying like most
of the things we deal with are covered
by three surgeries we'll do
have to know more in the medical center
there and Northern surgery and the 200
000 pounds has arrived at by the
clinical commissioning group with their
formula down very workout uh number of
properties and how many people it's
likely after kids but that's how they
walk out of the stuff it's not the
applicants off of that it's not
requested often and
the series one well perhaps it wrote
Reserve matters I was talking to our
planning managers are in the lunch
screen we'll get started in system more
information
I'd like to be a reserved methods today
then they can cope with these increased
roles
and the only thing I would mention I
think we'd like to see I've not been
able to see it in the conditions Alan
might tell me if I'm wrong with that
some kind of a landscape came in here
because the nation is raised by the almb
and the fact that the battery was
through the road or then I call it even
then
just need some kind of landscaping along
that it's not just uh at the back
control of the residents will move in
there who will say oh I'm going to put
that engine who's there I've got a
viewer out there so I think we need some
kind of a yeah should I comment yeah
yeah so
the concerns of the aomd team have been
noted and the eventual layout scale and
appearance of the driving but as members
are aware of the detailed stage and
there is a condition condition combined
on
that's recommended which requires a
design code and there's a lot of stuff
points that are set out there so
Landscaping in itself will be a reserved
matter but on something of this scale
and actually where there is this step
facility with the area of outstanding
natural beauty so you could either have
a dedicated condition requiring a
landscape mitigation strategy with
reference the OMB but or we can
incorporate a sub Point into condition
five that specifically require the
design code which looks at all manner of
things specifically consider landscape
mitigation to protect the setting of The
OMB and I think that would be the proper
way to do it it just means that that's a
very key key issue that needs to be
looked at at the beginning of the
reserve maximum process so either of
those would work maybe the Divine code
is the easiest way to do it after other
if you're happy yeah
all right
and of course
we must realize that hopefully we'll get
the full 30 percent according to us
councilman Hopper leaving me too on the
site and we're going to bear in mind
when you look at the developments we've
been dealing with nowhere
the large ones within the debating
there's so many demands made out of
application such as to provide 100
000 for this twenty thousand for that it
talks I mean some of the things that you
know bus services online we looked at
this point it was about six hundred
thousand pounds
all this answers up to a colossal amount
and I'd much rather see the main thing
for me is affordable housing on science
before all the issues and all the
infrastructure like doctors surgery was
about and even this morning they were
talking about the hospital well with no
control over the NHS and whether they
extend the hospital it's down to be
extended in the hospital with no sale
with that and neither development sites
in our area and he said
it's worth it bearing in mind the added
costs that are always being asked for
and then you get liability issues coming
on it's much more important for
residence councilman that we get the
affordable the medium in the area
[Music]
[Music]
and I believe there is a condition
requiring a length so that that's
basically the ongoing management of all
of the habitats and the landscape on the
site and and that that quite fundamental
for the development that's where
significantly follows on by election
questions the biological field yeah that
is described all about a biological
field that's a quite the end of the
description
um
what is that I mean for biology and
Wildlife to survive it seems to me
you've got to keep the humans and the
Dogs Out
let's see 106 agreement putting dishes
off that's that make biology and
environmental matters you know Thrive
which basically means keeping the public
out what is going to be the situation
there
um because you need to be doing
something I see is only one to five
years in the end of five years
then we can do what we like again so
we're doing
and does that mean that somebody can
come back and then build on it after
five years and I applied the building
after five years
yeah so so the the off-site net gain
which is identified with any biology
field and I think providing that game
doesn't automatically have to be
separate to do human activity
um the condition
26 requires detailed mitigation measures
and it's deemed to achieve at least 10
by the net gain so that covers the
biology field and the site itself
the application that's imported by an
indicative biodiversity statement team
to show how that would work and what
would come forward the section 106 is
going to secure that biology field so a
combination of condition 26 and any
requirements in the section 106 will
step
the
specification of that net gain how it
will be managed importantly yes
um and it gives part of that it's
necessary to restrict access then that
would be incorporated within within the
section 106 and the mitigation strategy
and even until we know exactly what that
biodiversity Net game is going to be
difficult to automatically say now where
the public can access it or not
um and it would be required for a
30-year period yes that's the
requirement so in the legal agreement we
find that in
so you wouldn't then be able to go and
build and build on that therefore with a
biological net gain there must be a
plantation Point have we got a
foundation Point yet the measure whether
that game starts yes so the the
submitted ecological impact assessments
that's that current sort of Baseline of
what the habitat units are on the side
of the moment what impacts the
development will have and then the net
the indicative Net game scheme has to
compensate for what's lost and provide a
10 addition so your offices are
confident on the basis of the executive
scheme that's been provided which will
be secured by a recognition
um at the appropriate stages and
certainly probably pre-commencement in
terms of the biodiversity specification
that that will deliver the 10
um I don't have we don't have the
absolutely
thank you
thank you yeah and that biological area
down to the bottom corner it is
yeah I'd just like go back on obviously
this is a strategic site which we put
into local plan and I'm assuming that
the authority went actively that I've
known is to invite them to put forward
the sites in the beginning of the local
book so yeah you know just just sort of
public no you know this site's already
been allocated you know we've gone out
to Tender as such and I see developers
or landowners put us forward so
just what I confirm but when we go back
to I'd like to touch on the developers
itself you know thankfully it's a it's a
local company and you've got proof of
the infrastructure with the tag won't be
development at the moment that's the
only development I know around the area
it's actually producing infrastructure
road coming through from go flex
relative Atlantic way
which will take away some traffic coming
a lot of traffic coming from northern
Village and the fact that going down to
the Village Westwood home as well so
proofs in the put in what they're doing
so far what they're delivering for the
areas it's not as if they're coming to
make a quick Buck quick profit and
disappear
I understand they've got to make profit
because that's that's the idea of
business they're in business to make
profit but then most of it's local trade
so the local economy is going to be
boosted again and it's kept local in the
area that's means local economics and
that's what we need around the area so
supporting local business is what we
should be doing as well but I just
thought highlight again about the
affordability which uh you know that
that's me is the main priority for me
yeah have a good effort thank you
right
I think that's everybody's made the
contributions
and I'm glad to see we're getting
a form will pick around the area down
there which is longer than what was
proposed
and I'm pleased about that and I think
there's a green space than having been a
bit with allotments
and
and the channel I've got here says total
290 dwellings in history that's that's
the future discussion there are things
so it sounds interesting because take me
back answer question no sorry cancel it
off
[Music]
and we do need Clarity on the position
put by the highway Authority in terms of
flexibility for obligation
okay I'm quite happy for the holiday
Ways by the flexible thing yeah yeah I'm
more happy for Next Period of high waist
if you want the cycleways to go through
and the things that is going through
normally if it's major things we need
the flexibility it's a spring catch we
need the flexibility to draw on these
monies because that's what we're
desperately at the moment as a financial
account so we are struggling that's why
we need the flexibility to recite
delivering these projects exported by
the public so I'm in full support all
right so with those two
[Music]
thank you chair councilor Benson cancer
brown or censor Christie against
cancer leather or pencil or not for
canceling the goal four councilor
Pennington or pencil Wiseman
seven four and one again
I need I need to leave to go to Exeter
thank you you're an excuse me
rightly
we move on the 1980s on our agenda and
revealed decisions there are no appeal
decisions nine on the agenda is not here
with no cost by opinion
I can turn on things and we make the
seventh of the agmv application
[Music]
item 11 on the agenda finding decisions
for advantages
decisions uh between the 14th of July 22
on the 22nd of September 20th
[Music]
fighting 12 on the General Session there
is no path here in their current session
so
with thanks brother too you didn't
actually ask for any comments on this
could I make a comment on one yes or
post 207
the third one from the top
part retrospective application for
destruction of intact dwelling if it's
your expected one assumes it's already
started yet we're refusing what happens
now is he got to knock it down
yes so
if something has been yeah particularly
retrospective application and it's been
reviewed then it is open to accountants
in there's a slightly not everything
automatically follows that we would take
unfortunate action if the text is
whether it's in the public interest
identity exact details of that and where
that is in that process counter crispy
but that's certainly appears into
account to to require that
before you close to me you're gonna ask
um did anyone would say in the what
would be all of the plan inspector would
be it's in caught by the court
yeah so
um it was a I think as you're aware with
a much reduced inquiry it was only one
day
um and it was very much just talking
about the conditions the planning
obligation although in the morning third
class we were able to speak and we we
provided a facility here but if we
wanted to come and do that in person
will be at virtually
um which I think was well received a
number of people did turn up here
despite the bit took place
um on Thursday morning of last week and
we haven't been given a date for when we
can expect the decision
um I would hope that we'll be inside
imprisonment and that yeah there was
sort of interacting the selection and
points off by the inspector in the
planning obligation and
um the condition and cleaning seemed
okay so I think we're always Keen to get
support and respect with that obligation
that we're routinely thinking our
self-compliance so it will be important
to see what's included on that
um yeah we obviously don't have a have a
decision at this point in the time so I
would hope
foreign
[Music]
my understanding is that that is being
moved through the system
um when we have a request for a TPO it
involved them going out and carrying out
Tempo so it's a sort of an assessment as
to whether certain criteria are matched
um I can check on that for you then we
can drop you an update I think it's
already is it already I know it's going
on
right only half of that has all right so
you can raise it a nice meeting and then
we checked that so I thought the whole
word
check it yeah I would have been
redesignated relations with them by them
down and yeah I I couldn't quite
understand why divide everyone goes down
the long axis
yeah
I just ask about the uh August the 8th
quarter coaster where we discuss the uh
with development we run the part two
are we allowed noting to to talk about
it to our parishes because amateur power
strokes or how to go to the evening
after on August the 9th and that you
know it was very difficult meeting
um I don't want to be great in part two
but I do feel I want to be accountable
to
um the electorate basically so are we
still under part two or has that been
lifted though
um so it's all there out there the only
reason it was part two was because I
didn't want to Prejudice the
negotiations that we were having to
developed before we got to the inquiry
and just it will be brought before
establishments
failed to explain
[Music]
application was accepted by the
inspector for consideration without
those having any input at all without
any perishable Town caps with other hand
but yeah
and and in the here in the day so I I'm
very impressive
our side of it anyway because things
were put in at the 11th Barrel which
should have been earlier things like
viability of the business being
reassessed yeah there we are I reckon
your ground
foreign